virtual annual meeting of berkshire
hathaway we did an omaha last year on
short notice we had
more warning this time and so we came to
uh
los angeles and the reason we're doing
it from here is because of the man on my
left
not because he asked for it but because
all of us wanted to do it with charlie
in in in here in los angeles so
i'll introduce the
three vice chairman of berkshire in a
minute
i'll show you the first quarter earnings
we won't take much time on that i'll
have
one or two very short lessons for
perhaps the new investors who are not
necessarily in berkshire hathaway but
people who have entered the stock market
in the last year and there's i think
there have been a record number that
have entered the stock market
i'll have a couple of little uh examples
for them and then we'll swing into a
q a led by becky
who's looked at thousands of of uh
questions that have been submitted to
her but more can be submitted during
this meeting and we will put up
on camera from time to time
the way you can communicate directly
with her if you want to send
questions in during the meeting she got
flooded with them last time
and uh she miraculously keeps sorting
them out and
so feel free to send send in a question
and we will have a question period
for about three and a half hours and
then we will finally have the annual
meeting
which won't take long uh at the end so
with that uh i would like to
first introduce the three vice chairman
of
berkshire hathaway i'll tell you just a
little bit about them and then i'll have
a
mild surprise for you at the end perhaps
uh
on my left uh
charlie munger and i met charlie
62 years ago he was practicing
law in los angeles
uh he was uh building a house at that
time
a few miles from here and 62 years later
he's
still living in the same house now that
was kind of interesting because i was
buying a house
just a few months before 62 years ago
and i'm still living in the same house
so you've got a couple of
fairly peculiar guys just to start with
in terms of their
love affair with their their homes uh
and charlie charlie and i
uh get it off immediately and
uh uh i would say he's
i he's probably the vice chairman in
charge of culture
among other things but if i ever want to
get questions about where true north is
i talk to charlie and he has been an
enormous help he's done it with a lot
fewer hours and a lot less talking and
everything that i have but he's
contributed an
incredible way to uh to berkshire so
charlie's been out here in los angeles
for
60 plus years uh on my right
your left i have uh
the vice chairman in charge
of everything except insurance and
investments
great able greg was born and raised
in edmonton alberta he's canadian
plays hockey his eight-year-old plays
hockey and
he came to the united states
sometime after he graduated from college
in
canada and he is in charge of a
business which has uh
well over 150 billion in sales and
employs 200 and more than 250 000
probably 275 000 people
and uh does a much better job
at doing that i was doing previously and
on my far left you're right you're right
we have a g
jane and the jeep was born and raised in
india graduated from college there
and i met a gene on a saturday in 1986
and
i'd been in the insurance business
berkshire had been an insurance business
for quite a while
and i was kind of stumbling around in
various ways and ajit came to the office
and
saturday i was opening my own and i said
uh
much you know about insurance
and he said nothing and i said well
nobody's perfect and
let's talk about it some and uh by the
end of the morning i knew i had somebody
that was going to
build a great insurance business and
starting from that
point this improbable little company
in omaha became
the largest property casualty company in
the world in terms of net worth
it writes risks that it right risks
righteous occasionally in a 24-hour
period that other
companies simply couldn't take on
themselves they'd have to assemble other
people would take them
a long time to come to a decision that
was very important at various times in
the past
it's not so important now but he's built
an incredible the world's leading
property casualty insurance company so
here we have
charlie from la uh 60-something years
we've got greg from canada
we've got ajit from india and
the one thing in common that these three
fellows have aside from working for
berkshire and doing a sensational job
the one thing in common is that uh
at one time or another uh for some
extended period
they lived within a mile of me in omaha
nebraska and
uh charlie in 1934
moved about 100 yards away from where i
now live
and went through high school eventually
went in the service uh
and uh knows the neighborhood as well as
i do went to the same
great school my kids went to and so on
greg
uh spent significant time in
living in omaha lived about five or six
blocks from me
now lives in des moines energy was in
omaha
about a mile away for a couple years so
we uh
started in very different places and
sort of came together and now
go our separate ways but it's all worked
very well and i urge you to
send questions if you're thinking you
can direct them to me or you can direct
them to
any one of the other three and it will
be a big relief to me if you direct a
fair number to the other people
so uh we
this morning as we always do
we always do it on saturday we published
our
attend queue which gave the quarterly
earnings it's up on our website
berkshire hathaway.com it's very
interesting we we
we put these out on uh saturday morning
that's not because the media likes us to
do it that way it's not because
the analysts like to do it that way but
we want to give you the maximum time
to digest an awful lot of information
that's in that tent
it it can't be summarized uh in a
perfect way we'll give you some summary
figures but
if you're really a student of the place
and most most of most of our investors
buy because they they simply have faith
in
in these other three fellows to do a
good job uh
and they that's not a misplaced faith
but if you really enjoy
going into the details and you want to
understand the
nuts and bolts of of trathway's various
operations
you should read that 10q and it may take
you a couple of hours i mean it's not a
small investment of time but it's got a
lot of information about
all our various businesses and for those
of you who are
business students of a sort uh i
recommend you go
you'll go to it the summary figures you
see here
which are the ones we put in our press
release uh
uh show kind of an interesting pair of
numbers i made it down there at the
bottom
you know we have uh last year when you
see those brackets around numbers you
get you know you got to start worrying
and uh first quarter we actually showed
a loss of
almost 50 billion dollars i never
thought i'd ever see a figure like that
and i was thinking back i i
was trying to remember whether i had
gone on vacation during that quarter and
turned things over to the other guys or
what
but i checked the calendar and that was
me uh
and uh that uh figure this year is a
positive figure
of 11.7 billion and neither figure
is very meaningful in itself the
accounting sanders board a few years ago
for many many many many years
unrealized gains or losses of a company
like berkshire
were made adjustments to the net worth
of berkshire but they did not run
through earnings and a few years ago
the rule was changed so that every time
the stocks go up or down it goes through
our earnings account
so in the first quarter of last year
when stocks went down a lot
we had a huge sum
of unrealized well it was a reduction of
unrealized gains largely
and when you start saying things like
that you start losing people but
uh uh
that item the mild plus
this year but if you if we reported
earnings daily you would see
earnings one day of 3 billion next year
the day of minus 3
2 billion and it's it's an accounting
treatment that we don't think is
particularly appropriate but
but it's required and we explain
very carefully both in our press
releases are we trying to explain and
and i try to write on my letter and
explain why i don't think that's the way
to look at berkshire we think over time
that we will have investment gains for
reasons i lay out in my letter
uh over a period of time the companies
we own stock and retain
earnings and and they uh
they use those reinvested earnings
usually to our benefit
and that shows up in capital gains
someday but
reported earnings for a company that has
a lot of
common stocks marketable stocks like
ours uh
you don't want to look at that final
line and
uh you do want to look at the operating
earnings
line now i would say that that uh
if you had taken the first two months of
last year and compared to the first two
months of this year
those figures would have been quite
comparable but of course in march
of 2020 the economy
was shut down in effect i mean it was a
self-induced
uh uh recession and an abrupt one
very abrupt and so uh uh
economy went off a cliff in in in march
it was
it was uh it was uh
resurrected uh in an extraordinarily
effective way
uh by federal reserve action
and and uh and later uh
on the fiscal front by congress and
we'll get into that later but
uh uh the
figure figure you see uh
that uh
the difference was march basically uh
the two
and our businesses are done uh we'll get
into
more specifics later but our business
has been really quite well
this has been a very very very unusual
uh recession in that it's it's been
localized as the industry uh to an
extraordinary extent and
uh right now is really
very good in a great many segments of
the economy
which we'll talk about later but there's
still problems if
if you're in the if you're in a few few
types of business that really have been
decimated you know such as
international air travel or something of
the sort so with that
we'll we'll go back to the figures later
on uh
but perhaps and some of the questions i
would like to
just go over two items that i would like
particularly new entrants to the
stock market to uh ponder just a bit
before they try and do 30 or 40 trades a
day
uh in order to profit what from what
looks like in
a very uh easy game so these i
on march 31st i ran off a list of the 20
largest companies in the world
by stock market value those names good
many of which will be familiar to but
they were led by apple at slightly
over 2 trillion and
it went down to the number 20th was
worth 330 odd billion
but those are the 20 largest companies
in the world by market value on march
31st
i was hoping i could get a little uh
quiz machine so i could have a really
weigh-in on this answer and we could
flash it up a little later but
proved technically impossible for but
what i would like
you to do is look at that list
starts off with apple and saudi aramco
is a pretty
kind of a specialized country as a
company
it's i don't know whether it's 95 owned
by the government or what but but it's
it's essentially a country that's for
sale in terms of that business
but the the top of the top
six companies five of them are american
so when you hear
people say that america hasn't
done it's gotta it's not working very
well or something of the sort
you know in the whole world uh of the
six top
companies in value five of them in the
united states
and if you think about it you know we
talked a little about this last year but
in 1790 we had one half of one percent
of the world's population
and a little less we had four million
people 3.9
million people 600 000 of them were
slaves
ireland had more people than the united
states had russia had five
times as many people as the u.s ukraine
had twice as many people as the united
states
so here we were but what did we have
we had a map for the future an
aspirational map
that uh somehow
now only 200 and well after the
constitution 200 232 years
uh later leaves us uh with five of the
top
six companies in the world
you know it's not an accident and it's
not because we were way smarter
the way stronger you know anything to
sort
we had good soil a decent climate
but so some of those other countries i
named uh
and the system has worked
unbelievably well just imagine thinking
of
five of the top six companies in the
world ending up with a country that
started with a half of one percent of
the population
uh just a few hundred years ago
but what i would like you to do is look
at that list
for a minute or two if you want to and
then make an
estimate make your own guess how many of
those companies are going to be on the
list 30 years from now
here they are these powerhouses and how
many would you guys are going to be on
the list
well you know it's not going to be all
20. it may not even be
all 20 today or tomorrow
this was march 31st but what would you
guess
and think about that yourself would you
put on five
eight well whatever it would be
slide two which goes back a little more
than 30 years
and look at the top 20 from 1989
and if you look at the top 20 from 1989
there's two things that we should grab
your interest
none of the 20 from 30 years ago or on
the present list
none zero there were then six u.s
companies on the list and their names
are familiar to you
we have uh general electric we have
exxon
ibm corp and these are they're still
around
merck is down there at number time none
made it
to the list 30 years later zero and i
would guess that very
few of you when i asked you to play the
quiz a little a few
minutes ago would have put down zero and
i don't think it will be zero
but it is a reminder of what
extraordinary things uh
going to happen things that seem obvious
to you japan had this wonderful
bull market for a very long time so you
had a number of japanese companies on
the list
today there there are none and
the united states had the six now we
have 13. uh but they aren't the same six
i would invite you to think about one
other thing as you look at this list
1989 was not the dark ages i mean we
weren't just discovering capitalism or
anything else
and people thought they knew a lot about
the stock market and the efficient
market theory was in and they were
it was not a it was not a backward time
and if you look the top company at that
time had a market value of 104 billion
so the largest company in the world uh
title in just shade over 30 years
has gone from 100 billion to 2 trillion
at the bottom the number 20 has gone
from
34 billion to something a little over 10
times that
that tells you something about what's
happened with equality which is a hot
subject in this country it tells you
a little bit about inflation but this
was not a highly inflationary period as
a whole
but it tells you that that
capitalism has worked incredibly well
especially for the capitalists and uh
then it's a pretty astounding number do
you think you you think it could be
repeated now that
that 30 years from now that you could
take two
trillion for apple multiply any company
and come up with
30 times that for the leader you know it
seems impossible and
maybe it is impossible but i just
we were just as sure of ourselves as
investors
and wall street was in 1989
as we are today but the world
can change in very very
uh dramatic ways and
i'll just give you one other example you
might ponder this is when you start
feeling too sure of yourself
one thing it shows incidentally is that
that uh
it's a great argument for for index
funds is that
you know the main thing to do is to be
aboard the ship you know
a ship you know they were all going to a
better promised land used to know which
one
was the one they'd necessarily get on
but but you couldn't
help but do well if you just had a
diversified group of equities
uh the eos equities would be my
preference but
uh to hold over a um 30-year period
but if you thought you knew a lot about
which ones to pick or the person that
you had hiring you were paying a lot of
money to
had all these ideas they could tell you
their best ideas and
1989 did not necessarily do that well
although overall
equities were absolutely uh
the place to be um
secondly uh people
get enormously attracted to various
industries i mean they think if you
think if you know the company says it's
in
the xyz industry and that's a popular
one you can you can sell ipos you can
you can sell spax you can people
disregard
sales numbers earnings numbers it's just
you know it's the place to be
so berkshire hathaway where was the
place to be in
1903 when my uh my dad was born in 1903
but
that wasn't really that big of news but
but it wasn't big news that actually
henry ford was starting the ford motor
company failed a couple of times before
but he was about to change the world i
mean the
the auto when you think about everything
we've got a great auto insurance company
but if there weren't any autos we
wouldn't have geico uh
the but it transformed the country
uh and then report brought in the five
dollar
daily wage and that was a huge thing
assembly lines uh everything
autos came along so let's just assume
that you had seen
a quick glance back in 1903 of
all the interstate highways 290 million
vehicles on the road in the united
states you know everything about it and
say well this is pretty easy it's going
to be cars
it's going to be autos berkshire by
accident
well we own a company called marmon we
bought it from the pritzker family some
years ago
the pritzkers uh had built this
business from many many many companies
that they'd acquired
and the name of their company was marmon
and
i don't know exactly why jay and bob
decided to name it marmon but they owned
this
company marmon which in 1911
had been a uh uh
the company whose car won the first
indianapolis 500.
uh and maybe that's why they called it
martin they were proud of the fact that
the company in 1911 named the ferdinand
won the first indianapolis 500 and also
was the company that invented the
rear view mirror i'm not sure whether
that was a big contribution to society
and
certainly around your household
here you don't want to emphasize too
much but but they uh
the car that was entered in the
annapolis 500 the the guy who normally
sat next to the driver and
looked backwards to tell what what the
competitors were doing he was sick
so they they invented the rearview
mirror so let's just assume
that you decided that
autos were this incredible thing and
someday there'd be an indianapolis 500
and somebody
ever reviewed mirrors on cars and
someday 290 million cars would be
buzzing around the united states
or autos trucks there
uh and so i decided to look
at the history and i thought i'd put up
the list of
auto companies from over the years
i was originally going to put up just
the ones that were the m so i could get
them on one slide
but when i went to the m's it went on
and on and on so i just decided to put
up the ones that started with m
a and as you can see there were almost
40 companies
that went into the auto business just
started with m.a including our little
our marmin there in the middle column
which uh
uh lasted for a while quite a while but
uh it was selling cars in
1930s were really quite special but in
any event
there were at least 2 000 companies
that entered the auto business because
it clearly had this incredible future
and of course you remember that
in 2009 there were three
left two of which went bankrupt so
there is a lot more to picking stocks
than what figuring out you know what's
going to be a wonderful industry in the
future
the maytag company put out a car all
stay put on a car
who put out a car i mean nebraska there
was a nebraska motorcycle
everybody started car companies just
like everybody's starting something now
that can be
where you can get money from people but
there were very very very
few people that picked the winner or
guess they got the opportunity for
at ford motor and before they had a few
partners and he really didn't like him
so i figured a way to buy them out that
was
one it was sort of the beginning of the
uh the auto finance so that's a long
story we won't get into that but
you couldn't buy in the ford motor and
of course general motors became the
the dominant company finally when henry
ford did not really make the
shift from the model t to the model a
very it did not work very well
so i just want to tell you it's not as
easy as it sounds
and with that uh we will go to uh
becky quick and and uh she will ask
any of the four of us questions she has
selected and
which we don't uh she doesn't share with
us you're well known for
saying to be fearful when others are
greedy and be greedy when others are
fearful but by all appearances berkshire
was fearful when others were
most fearful in the early months of
covet dumping airline stocks at or near
the low
not taking advantage of the fear
gripping the market to buy shares of
public companies at exceptional
discounts
and being hesitant to buy back
significant amounts of berkshire stock
at very attractive prices
until both monetary and fiscal policy
kicked in
uh well you knew we had an
incredible problem and that our
i am as justice charlie is the chief
culture officer i'm i'm the chief
chief risk officer of berkshire that's
that's my job that
uh we hope we do well we want to be sure
we don't do terribly
uh but we didn't sell a
uh substantial amount i mean we're a
company with
six probably 700 billion dollars worth
of businesses some we own in in their
entirety with some we own a piece of and
i don't know whether we were sellers
maybe one percent
of the value of all the businesses we
had at that period but
the airline is kind of interesting with
the airline businesses in particular
and then i'll get to what was done in
fiscal monetary policy
but we had a few people
various subsidiaries of berkshire that
wanted to go in for help
from the government and uh
in some cases they had minority
shareholders owned a few percent and
they said well this is you know
we're going to get killed by what's
happening uh when
uh with the regulations that are being
put out and then we're stopping the
economy and and
they said everybody's going in for him
and why don't we go and i said
uh you know berkshire can handle it
this is for people that can't handle
what's happening and we so we're not
applying
but the airlines
were the most prominent beneficiaries of
of uh of what took place immediately
they got 25 billion
uh initially most of which went to the
big four airlines and some of which went
in as grants
not not loans uh and
you know i i think that was fine public
policy i think it
i was wishing he could go to every
restaurant and dry cleaner and every
small business
that really was out of business and had
no one
no i mean they they were they were they
were they were made toast
you know basically uh but the airlines
clearly
what happened was not their fault in any
way shape or form it wasn't like 2009
when people blamed the banks
and hated to see them help so it was now
airlines
operate in bankruptcy so it isn't like
that
the three of the four big ones when i
went through bankruptcy and
within the previous standards so the
airlines were kind of used to operating
impacts they would have kept operating
but
it was perfectly proper for the airlines
to be
held the entire airline business you
know you look at these figures of 2
trillion for apple and so on
the entire big four airlines they were
they sold for about 100 billion dollars
almost i mean it's
so very very small combined they
wouldn't come close to making the
the cut i mean they wouldn't be in the
top 50. uh
so anyway uh they went into the
government they needed a government help
or they needed or they could
would go bankrupt some of them and uh
and uh
uh really the congress but steve
minuchin tube uh that they decided they
deserve the help which i i do not
quarrel with at all
but imagine if berkshire was the ten
percent older which they had been
of everyone their lenses and to get them
berkshire i mean
it's it'd be like one of our they would
have had they might have very well had a
very
very very different result if they'd had
a very very very rich shareholder that
owned eight or nine percent that uh
and they didn't have that uh you know
when they went in
so our you might not have gotten the
same result
in fact i would i would think you
probably wouldn't i mean i can just see
the headlines now i mean they
you know because you've seen the
headlines on some companies that took
100 million or two
you know and really didn't need it and
some of them gave it back and most of
them gave it back
uh but you're looking you're actually
looking at it probably at a different
result than if we kept our stock
but in any event an industry that
was really selling for less than a
hundred billion dollars uh
lost a significant amount of money
they lost perspective earning power i
mean right now they're
you know international travel's not come
back but i would say overall too that
the economic recovery has gone
far better than you could say with any
insurance so we
uh we didn't like having as much money
as we had in banks
at that time so i i cut back some of the
bank investment
but basically our net sales were about
one percent
one and a half percent and and looking
back you know
it would have been better better to be
buying but but i do not consider it
i do not consider it a great moment in
berkshire's history but i also
we've got more net worth than any any
company in the united states
under accounting principles and we've
got we've got
six or seven hundred billion of
generally good businesses
and uh uh
i think as i think i think the airline
business has done better because we've
sold and i wish him well
but i still uh i still wouldn't want to
buy the airline business
international people really want to
they want to travel uh for personal
reasons and
and uh uh business travel
is everything and we've got a big
exposure to business travel of course
through the fact that we own 19 of
american express
and we own precision cash parts which
services the
they are business very demands so we've
we still got a big investment
in uh air travel
uh a big commitment to it but but uh
we wish the big four the best and and
i think their managements have done a
very good job during this period
you spent years accumulating cash
insisting you had your elephant gun
ready
the march 2020 listed equity sell-off
came with promises from the us
government that they would do what it
takes
yet you sat on your hands please help me
understand what i missed
we have about i think our cash on hand
has been about 15 of our our values
of our businesses and uh
that's that's a healthy chunk and i'd
say it'll never get below 20 billion but
we're
we're going to raise that number because
it's just the size and
importance of berkshire uh
but we we uh we could have deployed
uh 50 or 75 billion
uh and right before the fed act
i mean we hit a point uh
where the calls were two calls came in
uh but it was two or three days and
nothing could happen
when jay powell acted as he did
that was incredibly important i mean i
shouldn't say the fed
acted as they did but they they moved
with speed
and a decisiveness on march 23rd
that changed the situation where the
economy had stopped
the government bond market was even
disrupted berkshire hathaway
probably could not have gone out with a
debt offering uh
the day before that uh there was a
didn't get a lot of publicity time but
there was a run on money market funds a
very substantial run
and uh if you look at the numbers daily
numbers on that
it was a repeat of september 2008
and this time i give great credit to
what bernanke and paulson did but this
time
the fed knew that saying whatever it
takes and saying it
and demonstrating it which they did on
march 23rd
they took a market where berkshire
couldn't sell bonds on the day before
and turned it into one where carnival
cruise lines or something solid a day or
two later it
and there was you know it's record
issuance of corporate debt
and uh companies losing money companies
were
closed whatever it was it was the most
dramatic
move that you can imagine and and at the
time as i remember the chairman
saying uh you know have a little help on
the on the fiscal front and
then congress acted very very big again
in 2008 and nine they argued
about you know we don't want to give
money money those dirty banks all that
sort of thing but this time there
there really wasn't anybody to blame so
uh
they had they saw what was necessary and
congress responded so you had fiscal
monetary policy that
responded in a way that was incredible
and it did the job
and it did it i think it did a better
job than either the fed or
the treasury or anybody expected i mean
this
this economy right now is
85 of it is is
running in super high gear and people
can't
uh you know and and you're seeing some
inflation and all of that
it it's responded in an incredible way
and we learned something out of 2009 and
then we applied
but i don't think it was a sure thing
that would happen and
the one thing about berkshire is we
never do we never want
we don't want to depend on anybody we're
not a bank we can't go to the federal
reserve if we need money
and we've got to we've got to be sure
that
under any circumstances any
circumstances we can't solve nuclear war
and maybe we can't you know
but you know branch dubois if you
remember in the streetcar named desire
said i depend on the kindness of
strangers
you can't depend on the kindness of your
friends if things really stop i mean
i've seen that in
several different places and we were
started we we were seeing it
on march middle march everybody was
drawing down the credit lines
the banks did not expect that they just
weren't sure they were going to be able
to draw it on their credit lines 10 days
later
and so they just drew them down and they
took the money out of
money market funds we got very prompt
i give great credit on both the monetary
and fiscal side of what was done
but i didn't think was the sure thing
that would happen and i didn't know how
it would be implemented
it's worked i think it's worked better
than just about
anybody is expected uh and
i think well you're seeing it now
you know charlie's got some views on
this too so we shouldn't leave him out
of it
well
it's crazy to think anybody's going to
be smart enough to
husband money and then just come out on
the bottom tick in some crazy crisis
and spend it all or always as some
person that does that by accident
but that's too tough a standard anybody
expects that of berkshire hathaway is
out of his mind
yeah charlie charlie and i never were
very good at dancing but we really can't
do that dance
no no we can't and by the way almost
nobody else can either
not with tens of billions yeah or
hundreds of billion
but it's worked out well we forgot to
show one of the financial sides
actually if you go back to the the
balance sheet but we
uh we did buy in in the first um you'll
see the shares outstanding if we go back
to
to uh what is it e3 the
e2 you look
slide e2 yeah
well the balance sheet yeah there it
shows the shares outstanding at the
bottom and we have
we have uh we spent about 25 billion in
the
first quarter and more money since and
we've it's the best thing
we can't buy companies as cheap as we
can buy our own and we can't buy stocks
as cheap as we can
buy our own so uh uh and we've been able
to do that with a fair amount of money
but looking i mean if you uh you know
definitely we could have done better
things and
we we would have sold them
we would have sold airlines and cut back
on banks regardless whether we should
have bought something else at the same
time another question
after a 15-year period of market under
performance
you're cautious about predicting
berkshire being able to outperform the
market in the future
given this what do you see is the
arguments for long-time shareholders to
continue
holding their stock versus diversifying
the risk across an index
charlie you want to answer that well
sure well i personally prefer holding
berkshire
holding the market so
i'm quite comfortable holding berkshire
i think our businesses are better than
the average in the market
is it because you don't think the market
values it fairly well these are just
accidents of history and
things are fluctuating at all times but
on a composite basis i'd bet on
berkshire over the market
that's assuming we're all dead yeah
i recommend it i i recommend the s p 500
index fund and
abs for a long long time to people
and uh i've never recommended berkshire
to anybody
uh because i i don't want people to buy
it because they think i'm
tipping them into some time never i mean
no matter what i was selling for
and uh uh and
you know i i made it public you know i'm
on my death there's a
there's a fund for my uh
that then widow and uh ninety percent
will
go into an s p 500 index fund and ten
percent of treasury
uh on the other hand i'm very happy
having my future contributions to
a group of charities that'll be spread
over 12 years or so after my death
to stay in berkshire i think the odds
are
berkshire berkshire is yeah i like it
but i'm not
i don't i do not think uh
the average person can pick stocks
we happen to have a large group of
people that
didn't pick stocks but they picked
charlie and me to manage money for them
50 or 60 years ago and and uh
so we have a very unusual group of
shareholders i think who
look at berkshire as a lifetime savings
vehicle
and uh one they don't have to think
about and uh
uh one that they'll look you know if
they don't look at it again for 10 or 20
years that
that uh will have taken care of the
money reasonably well
but that i wouldn't argue that s p 500
over time
i would i perfect i i like berkshire but
i uh
uh i think that the
a person who doesn't know anything about
stocks
uh at all and doesn't have any special
feelings about berkshire i think they
ought to
buy the s p 500 index i believe you've
directed the trustees of your estate to
invest substantial assets into the index
fund
isn't that a vote of no confidence to
your managers
well no it because we're talking about
way less than one percent of my estate
and uh one thing i'm going to do
incidentally i mean all rich people get
advised by their lawyers set up trust so
that nobody can see your will and all
that sort of thing
my will is going to be public record and
you can you'll be able to check at some
point
i'm telling you the truth about what is
going to get done but
uh 99.7 roughly in
my estate uh will either go to
philanthropies or to the federal
government and
and uh before it does it
i think i think berkshire is a very hap
a very good thing to hold but
for a given individual particularly
my wife i just think that that that
having a
a tiny fraction that which is all it
takes for her to do very well
for the rest of her life uh i just i
think that the
best thing to do is by by 90 on an
in an s p 500 index fund now
the index fund people naturally have
started
over the time they they market more more
and more products that are
that go to other indices and everything
so they're really starting to say to the
to the american public they're saying
well you can pick what continent to
invest in or you can pick one industry
and we'll sell you something for that
and when they just have gotten through
telling them you know you really don't
know anything about stock
just buy the whole index so uh so i
named the 500
indexes one but it's it's a tiny portion
but it'll be it'll be her livelihood and
she'll have all the money she needs and
way beyond it and that's that and but
i don't i don't mind having the 99.7
large portion of it assuming that law is
the same as now total philanthropy to be
uh to be kept in berkshire until they
finally are disposed of
can investors still assume an oil and
gas business that finds and produces oil
at low cost per barrel can generate a
sufficient return on capital for a long
time to come
well i i'll give you a ten word answer
to that
they uh uh you know uh
i can't remember all the questions that
were there but i would say that people
that are on the extremes of both sides
are
are a little nuts i
i i would hate to have all the
hydrocarbons banned in three years or
and
you know you wouldn't want a world it
wouldn't work and on the other hand
you know what's happening will be
adapted to over time just as we've
adapted them
to all kinds of things i do not think i
i'm interested i quote from 1997
because uh you know we've talked about
this before
we have no problem owning costco or
walmart you know and
a substantial number of their stores and
uh you know they sell cigarettes it's a
big item you know
it's something that brings people in
they know the price of cigarettes and
and
uh you know they put them up front and
uh so we don't
uh it's a very tough situation we made
that decision a long time ago when we
went to memphis
and and we looked at a business that was
a very very good business and it was
much less harmful
uh at least from everything i could find
out uh it was much less harmful
than smoking tobacco chewing tobacco was
and these were
decent people and they were running a
legal business and
they all chewed the back of themselves
they told me that their mother was 100
and chewing tobacco all these things but
charlie and i did go down in the lobby
of that hotel and we just
said to ourselves this is probably the
best business we've ever seen
and i called my then son-in-law helen
green bergen
he'd studied chewing tobacco on its
effects when he was working for
uh a nadir related organization and and
we decided not to do it but you know
would we
you know i see i used to see ads in our
paper from financial companies where i
knew they were terrible you know and i
it's it's a very tough thing to decide
whether you get in or out of a business
it's very tough time to decide what
what companies benefit society more than
others i mean it's
i don't know whether i think chevron's
benefited society in all kinds of ways
and i think it continues to do so and i
think we're going to need a lot of
hydrocarbons for a long time and we'll
be very glad we've got them
but i do think that the world's moving
away from them too and then
i that could change
uh i i i don't like making the moral
judgments on stocks in terms of
actually running the businesses but
there's something about every business
that you know what you wouldn't like uh
and uh uh
you know meat packers or anything
they're gonna throw a meat back
you know it there's
if you expect perfection you know in
your spouse or in your friends or in
companies you're not going to find it
and and uh
what you elect to do yourself if you own
an index fund you're going to own
and blame me chevron is not an evil
company in the least
and and uh i have no compunction about
owning in the least about owning chevron
and if
if we owned the entire business i
wouldn't i would not feel uncomfortable
about being in that business
charlie well i agree
you know you can imagine two things a
young man marries into your family
he's a english professor at
say swarthmore or he's uh he works for
chevron which would you pick cause i
don't see
i want to admit i'd take the guy from
chevron
wow i hope your daughters agree with you
the board recommended voting against on
the shareholder proposal regarding the
reporting of
climate-related risks and opportunities
please share with us more about the
against
recommendation well i think maybe
greg can talk a little bit about about
what berkshire has done as opposed to
uh uh in in terms of
of the environmental i would say this
it's very interesting
with everything that's being really i
think we have over a million
shareholders i mean you can't be 100
sure
because of street name and duplicate
accounts
but it certainly seems very very likely
uh i've had
and i get the letters that are written
to me i don't think i've had
uh i don't think i've been
three letters in the last year from from
shareholders
now i have them and our vote on this as
you'll see later is that
that overwhelmingly the people that
bought
berkshire with their own money voted
against those prophecies
but most of the votes for it were
whereby came from people who
never put a dime of their own money in
the berkshire and
uh so they uh and i don't think they've
read our annual reports and i don't
think they've read
the reports of berkshire hathaway energy
and i don't think
i don't think they know you know if i
talk about what we're doing in
high voltage transmission we're doing
more in any what kind of company of the
country
uh uh the president talked about what
what the government's going to do and
how important it is and you know
we have a record in that's overall
is incredibly good but but we have a
group of organizations
just generally and and and they're nice
people but they
they want us to answer a bunch of
questionnaires their way so they want us
to go to
dairy queen and borsheims and all those
people have them fill out reports
that show a bunch of figures when the
reports to counter the reports that
greg gets on berkshire either way energy
and the railroad and
you talk about three of our companies
and you've covered 95 of it
uh and it's asinine frankly in my view
now we do some other asinine things
because we're required to do them so
we'll we'll do whatever's required
but to have the people
at you know business wire
you know dairy queen all these places
philly got reports to make it some
common report that comes in
we don't do that stuff at berkshire
we've got during the
during the pandemic we probably have
about 12 people to come into
headquarters and we've got
you know 360 000 people working in
in a company that that
that all kinds of diverse activities and
and it's built i don't want to get in
the whole thing it's spilled on
autonomy and and i am probably the only
ceo
of an s p 500 company that does not get
a consolidated income statement
uh every month i mean every other
company i'll bet in the s p 500
prints out the earnings they had but
then you know from
february and march and ceo gets and a
whole bunch of other people get it
i don't get it i don't need it you know
and and i could put
six years seventy companies in a whole
lot of trouble and everything
and they'd hand me something and i know
the answer to it already and it
didn't make any difference i mean
they've got the money they need
so we don't do things uh
just because we've got a department of
this or a department of that and we
don't want to set up a lot of
departments like that and and
what's important is what we're doing
in the well primarily berkshire hathaway
energy and the railroad i mean that's it
and uh i'll let greg tell you about that
uh in just one second but the uh
uh we're not i don't think we think we
know the answer to the
all these questions about global warming
and so forth and the people ask the
questions think they know the answers
we're just more modest
well but even if we knew the answer i
mean in terms of what we the reports we
would
yeah we would not collect a whole lot of
things
that don't mean anything to us and and
to satisfy people who actually don't own
any stock themselves and
in many cases i can tell i haven't read
our any report even the uh
you know we as i pointed out in the
annual report
and i never nobody would have guessed
that people think we're
a bunch of guys that own stocks and all
that sort of thing
berkshire hathaway owns
by gap accounting more property plant
equipment
business infrastructure which the
president's got to be talking about
wednesday night
in infrastructure importance of it we
have
measured by capricorning more than any
other company united states we have more
than any of those companies
that on the list of the largest
companies in the country but we've and
we've got it by a substantial margin
so we have an investment
in what makes this country move and work
15 percent of the interstate goods move
on them on our railroad and then
we're building transmission and we
started in
2006 or seven uh uh
planning how we would close coal plants
but you can't close coal plants
until you get the electricity from where
it's generated to the customer and if
you're going to generate it in wyoming
uh and it's going to go to las vegas or
some place
and previously they had a coal plant
near the place because that was the way
it was done
50 years ago or 75 years ago
you better have the transmission there's
no sense having the wind blow in wyoming
and people turn try and turn on the
lights in las vegas so we
we went at the transmission plan uh
question a lot earlier than people were
talking about and we've done
we said 16 billion or whatever it was in
the annual report that we
underway and we just added 2 billion
since the annual report
came out and there's no there's no
utility in the country that's coming
anywhere close to that
bhe and bnsf have our or have the
significant carbon
footprints when you think of berkshire
and
when you touched on the disclosure that
we've provided in the past going all the
way back to 2007
i did pull those uh two investor
presentations one from 2007
and then our most recent one in 2021 so
as a slide i think it would
just highlight going all the way back to
we've been doing investor presentations
for our
what we call our fixed income investors
and we've done that through every year
through 2021
we've provided very similar disclosures
to our board
on an annual basis and had discussions
around
berkshire hathaway's energies plans to
decarbonize
now it's interesting if you go back to
the 2007 fixed income conference
and we're having a conference at that
point in time we have third party debt
capital debt that our utilities raise
it's a traditional capital structure
used across our regulated entities to
manage our
our total cost to the customers so we
have investors
we present to them as we're highlighting
on on an annual basis
and if you go back to that 2007 investor
conference it's interesting
in that presentation we're highlighting
climate change
that it's a fundamental risk and we
taught and we discussed what good policy
would be
we discussed innovation we discussed
market transformation
and the importance of in the importance
of setting targets
at that point in time and and we had
recommendations for
our industry and then since then each
year we've presented
uh uh really a plan and a strategy
around
how each of our businesses in bhe but
each of our regulated entities
how they're going to transform and and
the whole
transformation has been around
decarbonization
managing that risk on behalf of our
stakeholders in our many states our
customers that we serve
and ultimately managing that risk for
berkshire hathaway's
shareholders now as you go through those
presentations
there's a common theme and warren
touched on it already
you have to build the foundation first
and that foundation is around building
the high voltage the transmission system
warren touched on it in his annual
report this year
and later he highlighted that at
berkshire hathaway energy will be
spending just in the west
18 billion dollars on transmission
5 billion of that's already been spent
as we see here
today and that 13 billion will be spent
over the
the next 10 years that that's the
foundation that then allows us to build
incremental
renewable resources and move it to our
many states that we stir
that we serve at berkshire hathaway
energy and
and well beyond that i would highlight
well we've been building the
the transmission infrastructure in place
we have been building renewables
if you look at our investment through
the
end of end of 2020 we've invested
30 billion dollars or in excess of 30
billion dollars into renewables
and have really completely changed the
way our businesses do business
i.e our utility businesses they've been
decarbonizing and delivering a valued
product to our
to our stakeholders to our to our
to our customers and i think the and i
think the results are
are really amazing when you look at them
and i'll give you a couple of reference
points
if you go back to 2015 when the u.s
was discussing excuse me joining the
the paris agreement very specific
targets were set
prior to those targets being set
berkshire hathaway energy and 12 other
companies including
the apples of the world google walmart
committed to paris and that targets
needed to be set
berkshire hathaway energy was one of
those uh companies in 2015.
yeah how many other utilities were there
right when there were no other energy
companies that that made any type of
commitment at that point in time
i'm happy to report we made a variety of
pledges
uh well one of them was at that point
we'd invested
15 billion dollars in renewables and
that we would commit
30 billion in total well we far far
exceeded that
total now so there's been a clear
commitment
to reduce decarbonizing our businesses
we have focused on very
identifiable quantifiable outcomes
and i think that's very important if you
look at the standards that were set with
the
or the original us government's
commitments associated with the paris
agreement
the target was 26 to 28
reductions in carbon footprints going
back to
2005 so that's the reduction period
through 2025 and they wanted
the 26 to 28 reduction level
we committed to that at bhe and i'm
happy to report
warning to we've briefed our board we
achieved that
in 2020. so we met our pledge
and we met the the commitment under the
paris agreement
and then if you fast forward to the
discussions that are occurring
right now or have occurred around
rejoining the paris agreement
the current administration has proposed
that
again using 2005 as a starting point
that the emission goals or reduction
should be 50 to 52 percent
by 2030. again i'm happy to brief to our
shareholders and
and and briefings we've provided to our
board
but berkshire hathaway energy will
achieve that by 2030
our reductions will hit the paris
agreement target again
the reason we can do it is we've built
the foundation through transmission the
substantial investment
that warns highlighted and then followed
that up
with very specific investments on the on
the renewable side
i have one incremental slide that i hope
sort of pulls it all together as people
discuss
carbon they often go to coal units
how many you own how many of you close
and there's no important that there's no
question that's can be an important
metric
but it is a transition and we have very
much focused across the three utilities
we own and the ones we've highlighted on
the slide
is to transition from our existing fleet
to renewables using transmission
we have not become overly dependent on
transitioning to gas that's been a clear
strategy
so over a period of time our coal units
will retire
i'm happy to report or please to report
to our shareholders that through
2020 we've closed 16 units
to date if you look at from 2021
through 2030 there'll be an incremental
16 units closed and then if you
go through to the end of 2049
our remaining 14 units will be closed
and at that point in time
all our coal units are are closed
that slide is just an aggregation of all
the activities each of our business
units have been taking
to help facilitate that transition and
really transitioning to a
decarbonizing those units and i said
decarbonizing our businesses on behalf
of
first and foremost our our customers the
the
the many stakeholders they represent in
their in the various states
and then equally important decarbonizing
those businesses on behalf of
of our berkshire hathaway shareholders
the only other thing i would add because
it is the
entity that has the second largest
carbon footprint
in in berkshire and when you combine
bnsf
and bhe you're talking the the
the material set of of emissions
within berkshire bnsf has also been very
active in managing
their carbon profile
they've committed to have science-based
targets established for 2030
so again those targets will again be
consistent with the paris agreement
we've seen what the other uh
participants or some of them in the
class uh in our in in the industry that
have committed to
and our commitment will be very similar
i it'll be consistent with the with the
paris agreement
but it'll be a 30 reduction in bnss
footprint
by 2030. so again if you look at our
and and that's been publicly disclosed
that's on the
uh bnsf website everything i've
discussed
regarding bhe is on their website
filed in aks completely accessible by
our many shareholders so when i look at
it on from the perspective of
our our berkshire shareholders i really
believe
this risk is being well managed and and
we're positioning ourselves for the
for the long term thanks warren
yeah incidentally i mean the president
the other night talked about 100
billion for infrastructure we'd love to
spend 100 billion on it
but uh uh he was talking about
you know transmission is is really
the problem i mean a big problem because
you gotta get
you gotta get from where the sun is
shining and where the
where the wind is blowing uh essentially
to
concentrations of population and and uh
uh it'll be whether the
you know you cross state lines and you
and you go through people's backyards
it's whether the federal government has
a better luck in just saying this is the
way it's going to be done ramming it
down
the throats of uh where they go and
getting it done i mean
they may have that power and they'll
they'll be able to do it faster than we
are
on the other hand we'd love to do it
we'll spend 100 billion
but the speed at which we can do it
is we bought pacific corp in 2006 and we
had a bunch of customers
out in the far west and and they had
coal plants
serving them and to change that you've
got to be able to go to where
wind blows and and and and deliver it so
it's
it's uh but it it
it is interesting that we have published
this information we spent more
far more than any utility than that in
terms of renewables and transmission in
the united states and we started with
nothing you know
a little operation but uh
our are the people who bought the stock
with their own money the individuals
they they seem to understand it and they
read the reports
and uh uh we get calls and they say well
we
we want to come out and talk to you
about it well we're not talking to them
and ignoring the million people who have
been with us over time and bought it
with their own money they
uh we we will not give special treatment
to
uh either the analysts or to the
to the uh to institutions over the
individuals that basically
trust us with our savings for their
lifetime my biggest concern is around
possible losses arising from higher than
expected insurance losses
we've seen this in other great companies
where underwriting mistakes end up
crippling businesses previously
considered
exemplar while i understand that
berkshire's culture is unique and the
insurance division is full of talented
individuals
this is a risk that concerns me many of
us shareholders feel comfortable now
given the privilege of having mr buffett
mr munger and mr jane looking at these
deals
however there will be a day when this is
no longer the case is it reasonable to
think that over the long term berkshire
should focus on playing vanilla short
tail insurance businesses like geico and
redis
reduce the size of some long tail risk i
want to clarify that i have the most
respect and gratitude for all of
berkshire employees that have built the
best insurance group in the world
i'm confident we have this talent to
remain leaders in this field for decades
to come
this is focused on the inherent
opaqueness and risk of some insurance
lines
i mean clearly contract certainty is an
issue for us in the insurance industry
it is an issue that cuts across not only
the long tail lines that you mentioned
but even short tail property focus lines
the most recent example
is business interruption which is
an integral part of any property
insurance policy that is bought and sold
by corporations
it is it is a risk every time we issue a
contract
that either because of sloppiness in
terms of how that contract is written
or because of the regulatory environment
we all have to live in
that the words in the contract may be
tortured
to and normally when they are tortured
they end up
going against the insurance industry not
in their favor
so it is a risk it's an
unknown risk in terms of how bad it can
be
i hope we price for it when we price for
the product we
throw in something for the unknown
unknowns if you will
and we try and aggregate our exposures
by major risk categories hopefully that
will give us
some comfort in terms of having some
boundaries
on what the exposure really can be
but there's no question the regulators
play a very important role in terms of
the economics of the business
especially in the u.s where there are 50
state regulators who
we have to deal with in terms of pricing
in terms of contracts in terms of
uh most of those surprises and insurance
probably all of them are unpleasant
i mean you get the premium on upfront
that's pleasant
and then from there on uh you get some
very imaginative
uh uh losses that come through and you
get something that you've taken on we
are willing to lose
uh in terms of sort of the outside limit
we think we're
willing to lose 10 billion dollars in a
single event and
uh we want to get paid very
appropriately for that
but uh we've got the resources to do it
and if
uh but
we we don't want to we don't want to
lose 10 billion in something where we
only thought we could
lose 50 million or something like that
and
you know the the current situation for
example with the boy scouts of america
you know
they uh the i think there were 1100
claims or something like that that have
been filed and now they're 17
000 just in no no they're close to a
hundred thousand now oh yeah and
up by 50 times and and these go back to
1950 or 1960 and you've got people
advertising
for claims and so all of a sudden you
get a lot of i'm sure a lot of the
claims are battle i'm sure a lot of them
are invalid and
and how in the world you pick out the
difference yeah and it goes back to
the issue that you just raised the the
the reason why this number of claims
have skyrocketed from less than 2000 to
close to 100 000
is because the statute of limitations
had expired
but in several states if not in most
states they have unilaterally
extended the deadline by which by when
you can make claims
and expanded it by a few years as a
result of which
a lot of more claims have appeared
funded by plaintiff lawyers who are now
very well funded
and that results in claims just
skyrocketing
yeah you get a lot of unpleasant
surprises and
and insurance but wait we've got a very
um i'm very biased on this but i i i
wouldn't
i think we've got the best insurance
operation in the world and i
and adidas the guy that created it and
and the people that geico
did we bought that and they did
wonderful things over time to contribute
their part of it too and
other people have but but ajit is a
symphony conductor of it
it looks like charlie and warren have
some different opinions recently like
costco
and wells fargo where's that taking
berkshire
charlie well we're not all that
different
and
costco is a company i very much admire
and i've enjoyed my long association
with that
that company and
but i love berkshire too so
and luckily there's no conflict and
lauren and i don't have to agree on
every damn little
thing we do we've gotten along pretty
well
we have better than pretty we have never
had an argument but yeah
that in 62 years and
it's not that we agree on everything we
literally
in 62 years we've never
never gotten mad at each other no it
just doesn't happen
as you two are clear leaders of the next
generation at berkshire hathaway can you
please tell us about how you interact
with each other
or some of the other incredibly
competent berkshire managers you seek
for advice
there's no question that the
relationship warren has with charlie is
unique and it's not going to be
duplicated certainly
not by me and greg no i can't think of
very many other pairs that can
duplicate it nevertheless uh both greg
and i
at least certainly from my perspective
and i'm sure greg will speak for himself
uh we've known each other for a very
long time uh
i certainly have a lot of respect both
at a professional level and a personal
level in terms of what
greg's abilities are we do not interact
with each other as often as warren and
charlie do
but every quarter we will talk to each
other about our respective businesses
and
update each other on our respective
businesses and then during the course of
the quarter while we may not have any
formal
sort of meetings if you will but every
time a question comes up which is
related to ques
insurance greg will pick up the phone
and call me by the same token if there's
any question that comes
up relating to any of the non-insurance
operations that greg is in charge of
like we had recently where a client of
mine was looking for
trying to find a buyer and i picked up
the phone and talked to greg and we
talked about
you know how best to proceed so there's
that that happens
during the course of the quarter every
quarter we exchange notes
and we have a perfectly
well functioning relationship between
the two of us
and i hope it remains that way greg
yes well as you well said and and as he
touched on
warren and charlie have a an exceptional
relationship
but very proud of the relationship ajit
and i've had and
as you touched on it's developed over
many years
we've had the opportunity or i've seen
the had the opportunity to see how
sheets run the insurance business and
as one highlight and charlie highlights
there's no one
better at it so i've had the opportunity
to observe that and then
equally over the years uh that
relationship has just built
and become greater and greater and as
she touched on could have more personal
respect for ajit both
personally and and professionally and
even though the interaction may be
different than say how
uh warren and charlie do it as egypt
touched on
there is a regular dialogue uh both
around opportunities within our two
businesses and units both if we see
something unusual that the other
other individuals should hear we make
sure we're always uh following up with
each other
but it goes beyond that uh ajit has a
great understanding of the
of the berkshire culture i i strongly
believe i do too and anytime we see
anything unusual in one of our
businesses
it's ajit who i'm going to call and say
are you comfortable
that we're taking this approach is it
going to be
consistent with how you think about it
how you think about it in insurance so
it goes
it goes beyond just discussing the
businesses but that
maintaining the exceptional culture we
have at berkshire and building upon that
so very fortunate to have ajit as a
colleague and
and and and immensely enjoy working with
them every day
it's on the profitability of geico and
bnsf he said why do these companies
operate at meaningfully lower
profit margins than their main
competitors progressive and union
pacific
can we expect current managements to at
least achieve parity
actually if you look at the first
quarter figures you'll
you'll see that
the berkshire hathaway union pacific
comparison has got
quite better katie farmers doing an
incredible job at
uh bnsf and uh uh
been an interesting question whether
five years from now or ten years from
now bnsf for
union pacific has the higher earnings
we've had higher earnings in the
past union pacific passes
the first quarter uh you can look at and
uh and uh
you know they think they've got a
slightly better franchise
we think we've got a slightly better
franchise we know we're larger than the
pacific i mean we will do more business
than they do and we should we should
make a little more money than they do
but we
we have in the last few years uh
uh but it's
it's quite a railroad i feel very good
about that
i should i should go back to the
previous question you know
people talk about the aging management
at berkshire and i always assume they're
talking about charlie
when they say that but but i i would
like to point out that
in three more years charlie will be
aging at one percent a year
and he is this no one is aging
less than charlie if you could take some
of these new companies
with 25 year olds they're aging at four
percent a year so
so we will have the slowest aging
manager percentage-wise
by far that any corporate
any american company has
did you want to talk about geico versus
progressive too because i got a lot of
questions on that
progressive and recent progressive has
had the best operation and
in the last in recent years in terms of
matching
rate to risk and that's what insurance
is all about among other things but i
mean you have to have the right rate
if you think that 90 year olds and 20
year olds have been
have an equal chance of dying i mean
you're you're going to be out of
business very quickly in the life
insurance business
and you will get all the 90 year old
risks and the other guy will get that 20
year old risks and the same thing
applies in
auto insurance i mean there's a huge
difference between
16 year old males and how they drive and
40 year old married
you know employed people
so the companies that do the best job
of actually having the appropriate rate
for every one of their policyholders is
going to do very well
and progressive has done a very good job
on that and we're
uh we're doing a much better uh
job on that already but and todd combs
has gone there and
and uh
it's a very interesting business both
progressive and geico were started in
the 30s
uh i believe i'm right about progressive
on that and we were starting 36.
you know we have had the better product
for a long long time i mean in terms of
cost and here we are
uh 80 85 years later in our case
and we have about 13 percenters over the
market whatever it may be and
progressive has just a slight bit less
so the two of us have 25
the market roughly in this huge market
after 87 years of having a better
product so it's a very
slow changing competitive situation but
progressive has
done a very very good job recently we've
done a very very good job over the years
and we're doing a good job now but we we
have made
some very significant improvements and
if you looked at the don't want to look
at the quarters too much but
but uh our profitability in the
first quarter was good but but we gave
back more money
under our give back arrangement when the
when the
virus broke out we gave 2.8 billion
on our give back program that was larger
than any company as well that's what was
the largest i think in the country
uh and geico and progressive are both
going to do very well in the future
and uh and actually the union pacific
and bnsf are going to do well in the
future it's just
in both cases we want to do a little bit
better the other guy
there's no question progressive is a
machine they're very good at what they
do
whether it's underwriting which warren
talked about in terms of matching rate
to risk whether it's handling claims
having said that i think geico is
catching up with progressive
more than a year ago about a year ago
progressive had margins that were almost
twice as much as guy codes
and growth rates that were almost twice
as much much as the crycos
if you look at the results as of now
progressive is still crushing it in
terms of growth relative to geico
but geico has certainly caught up with
progressive in terms of margins
and hopefully that gap will be
non-existent
in the future the second point i want to
make
on the issue of matching rate to risk
geico had clearly missed the bus
and we're late in terms of appreciating
the value of
telematics they have woken up to the
fact that telematics plays a big role in
matching rate to risk
they have a number of initiatives and
hopefully they will see the light of day
before not too long
and that will allow them to catch up
with their competitors in terms of the
issue of matching rate to risk
i will predict that five years from now
state farm is still the largest
auto insurer but i will predict it
five years from now it's very likely
that the the top two
will be geico and progressive in which
order we'll see
but but both companies are going to do
very well in my opinion
or they and they
geico's done well extremely well but
uh progressive was better at the uh
setting the right rate and and we're
catching up i think fairly fast
yeah progress excuse me progressive has
certainly done better
but when it comes to branding geico's i
think miles
excuse me miles ahead of progressive and
in terms of managing expenses as well
i think geico does a much better job
than anyone else in the industry
why didn't berkshire buy more of apple
stocks in 2020 this seems to be
counterintuitive
well we have five point three percent or
something like that now it's gone up in
the first quarter
because we bought in our shares which
helps our own shareholders
expand their interest in apple
indirectly
without laying out a petty and then
apple's repurchased its shares and just
announced another repurchase program so
uh let's say uh
we look at apple as a business that we
own
5.3 percent now we've got it's
a marketable security so it shows up as
uh
way greater than any other marketable
security we have but of course
if you look at our railroad that we
mentioned uh
well union pacific is selling for about
150 billion in the market and we own one
that's a
little larger than the union pacific and
making a little less money but not
not much less so it it's
ah it's a
it's an extraordinarily apple
it's got got a fantastic manager tim
cook was underappreciated for a while
he's one of the best managers in the in
the world
and i've seen a lot of managers and he's
got a product
that people absolutely love and and uh
there's an installed base of people
and they get satisfaction rates of 99
and i get the figures from the furniture
mart as to what's being sold
and if people come in and they want an
android phone
they want an android phone if they they
want apple
they want an apple phone you can't sell
them the other one i mean it the
the brand and
the product is is it's an incredible
product it's a huge
huge bargain uh to people i mean that
what the part it plays in their lives is
huge i use it as a phone but i'm
probably the only guy in the country you
know maybe
some descendant of alexander graham
bell's doing the same thing but
it is indispensable to people and
you know it costs you know car cost
thirty five thousand dollars and
i'm sure with some people if you asked
them whether they wanted to go had to
give up
their their uh apple or give up to
give up their car you know and maybe
make the choice for the next five years
you know who knows what they do but it
it is
it's and we you know we got a chance to
buy it and i
uh i sold
some stock last year although our
shareholders still had their percentage
interest go up
because we repurchased shares but that
was that was probably a mistake
in fact and charlie in
in his usual low key way uh
let me know that that you thought it was
a mistake too didn't shirley
yes yeah i it
i could only do so many things that i
could get away with with you
i kind of used them up between costco
and apple
uh so uh and
suddenly he probably he very likely was
right in both circumstances
it's it's an extraordinary business but
i do want to emphasize that uh
in his own way it's a different way but
tim cook is we we
see a lot of managers of a lot of
businesses and you're looking at two
great ones on the
both ends here uh
he's handled that business so well he
couldn't do what steve jobs obviously
could do in terms of of creation
uh but i don't
but steve jobs couldn't really i don't
think do what tim cook
has done in many respects
well i also think it's clear that that
list you
showed of the leading american companies
it's been
very important for america that we've
done so well in this
new tech field and i personally
would not like to see our present giants
brought down to some low level by some
anti-competitive
reasonings i don't think they're doing a
lot of harm
any competitively i think they're a
credit to the americans credit to our
civilization
and they're and they're huge and they're
huge and that's good for us
what's your mindset when you see so many
of these high flyers not the gme or meme
stocks but more like the big tech growth
stocks gaining 50
100 200 etc in a matter of a year or
less
how do you assess if these high flyers
are worthy of your investment given this
crazy high valuations that muddy the
waters
well we don't think they're crazy they
uh
but we don't at least charlie
i i feel uh that i understand
apple in its future
with consumers around the world
better than i understand some of the
others but i don't regard
uh prices and that gets back
uh well it gets it it gets back to
something fundamental in investments i
mean
uh interest rates
you know basically are to uh to uh
the value of assets what gravity is to
matter you know
essentially and and ah on the way out
here
i tried a little clipping from the wall
street journal yesterday
probably the only one that read it so
small and having trouble
finding it but anyway yes on thursday
the us treasury sold
some eight-week some four-week notes
uh treasury bills uh
and the price was in if you looked at
your wall street journal down a little
corner
next to last page in my paper you know
in the very bottom corner
uh the here it is
the results of the treasury auction
little tiny thing
they sold for they had applications on
the on the four-week
treasury bill for a hundred and
some billion they accepted bids for 40
43 billion worth
and it says average
average price one hundred point
zero zero zero zero zero zero
six zeros and essentially
people were giving 40 some billion
dollars to the registry
and they offered to give 130 billion or
something whatever the
amount tender and the treasury
received the money at zero uh
and janet yellen has talked a couple of
times about
the reduced carrying cost of the debt uh
i think in the last fiscal quarter u.s
treasury which
the us government which owes a few
billion a few trillion dollars i should
say
a few trillion dollars more than a year
ago their interest expense was down
eight percent so you've had this
incredible reduction in
the so-called super risk-free uh
group the short-term treasury bill and
that is the yardstick
against which other values are are
measured i mean if
if if i could reduce gravity
it's poll by about 80 percent i mean i'd
be in the tokyo
olympics uh jumping
and essentially if interest rates were
valuations or much so you've had this
incredible
change in the valuation of everything
that produces money
because the risk-free rate produces
really short enough right now nothing
it's very interesting i i brought this
book along because
uh for 25 or more years
paul samuelson's book was the definitive
book
on economics it was taught in every
school and and paul was a
he was the first he was the first nobel
uh prize winner uh it's sort of a cousin
to the nobel prize they started giving
in economics
uh i think in the late 60s he was the
first winner from the united states
paul samuelson uh
amazingly enough the second winner uh
was ken
arrow and both of them are the uncles of
larry summers
larry summers had the first two winners
his uncles uh
but paul he was a wonderful guy a
wonderful writer
the definitive writer and
uh so i got out the 73 economics books
and bear in mind probably economics kind
of started and
it's kind of an interesting science and
respect but with adam smith we'll say
you know he wrote the wealth of nations
in 1776 and he written some books
earlier but
it's sort of dated from kind of when our
country started and then you had all
these famous economists subsequently
and paul became the most famous of his
time so i looked up
in the back under interest rates i
looked for negative interest rates
there's nothing there so i finally
found zero interest rates and paul
samuelson
brilliant man after a couple hundred
years we've had us kind of studying
economics basically
he said that uh uh
he said you can conceivably
technically you can conceive perhaps
of negative interest rates but it can't
ever really happen
and that was in the 1970s this wasn't
back in the dark ages and this was a
and no economist wrote up and said this
is a terrible line to having a book
early
you know and here we are in this world
where
we had zero interest rates last year i
mean last week on a
or this week on a on a four four week
note
and berkshire hathaway which had a
has more than this but let's say we had
a hundred billion dollars in
in treasury bills we have more than that
before the va epidemic uh pandemic
we were getting about a billion and a
half from that a year
at present rates if it's two basis
points
we'd get 20 million imagine your your
wage is going from 15
an hour to 20 cents an hour so it it's
been
a sea change and it was designed
to be that i mean it was that's why the
fed moved the way they did
they wanted to give a massive push just
like
mario draghi did in europe and whenever
it was 2012 when he says whatever it
takes and they they
want the negative rates and uh we
fed us said it doesn't want to go to
negative rates and i think the treasury
actually has got some
small bar but but if you if
president rates were destined to be
appropriate
if the tenure should really be at the
price it is
those companies that develop mentioned
in this
question they're they're bargaining
they have the ability to deliver cash at
a rate that's
if you discount it back
and you're discounting at present
interest rates stocks are very very
cheap now the question is what interest
rates do over time
but there's a view of what interest
rates will be based in the yield curve
after
30 years and you know so on it it's a
it's a fascinating time we've never
really seen
what shoveling money in on the basis
that we're doing it on a
on a uh a fiscal basis while following a
monetary policy of
something close to zero interest rates
and it is enormously pleasant
but in economics there's one thing
always to remember you could
you can never do one thing you always
have to say and then what
and we're sending out
huge sums i mean president said it on
wednesday 85 percent of the people we're
gonna get a fourteen hundred dollar
check
you know we're about uh eighty-five
percent and
a couple years ago we were saying forty
percent of the people couldn't never
could come up with four hundred dollars
of cash so we've got
eighty-five percent of the people
getting those sums
and so far we've had no unpleasant
consequences from it i mean people feel
better
the people who get the money feel better
and and
people are lending money don't feel very
good but it causes stocks to go up
it causes business to flourish it causes
an electorate to be happy
and we'll see if it causes anything else
and if it doesn't cause anything else
you can count on it continuing in a very
big way
but there are consequences to everything
in economics but that is
that is why the googles and the apples
when we don't know we don't know
microsoft but they are incredible
companies in terms of what they re
earn on capital they don't require a lot
of capital
and they gush out more money and
if you're trying to find bonds that gush
out more
more money from the federal government
we've got a hundred billion business
shooting out
like you know 30 or 40 million dollars a
year whatever it may be depending on the
short-term race it's
uh so that puts the pressure on which is
exactly of course what
the monetary authorities want done i
mean that's they're pushing
the economy in a and they're doing in
europe you know even more extreme
and they're pushing and we're aiding it
with fiscal policy
and people feel good and and
people will become numb to numbers you
know trillions don't mean anything to
anybody you know
uh and uh and fourteen hundred dollars
does mean something to them
so we'll see where it all leads but it's
charlie and i consider it the most
interesting movie by far we've ever seen
in terms of economic stuff
yes and the professional economists of
course have been very surprised by
what's happened
it reminds me of what churchill said
about clement adley he said he was a
very modest man and had a great deal to
be
modest about and that's exactly what's
happened with the professional economist
they were so confident about everything
and it turns out the world is more
complicated than
they thought what's your opinion about
the economic theory mmt
um especially the united states because
it's the reserve currency for the world
well i think they're more the modern
monetary
theorists are more confident than they
ought to be too
i don't think we any of us know what's
going to happen with this stuff
i do think there's a good chance that
that this extreme conduct is more
feasible than everybody thought
but i do know if you keep just doing it
without any limit it will end
in disaster if you can borrow money at a
guaranteed low or even zero interest
rate as it's still worthy of borrowing
money for not that guaranteed cost from
the insurance operation
it reduces the value of float by a
substantial amount
and we have a flexibility with our float
that virtually
no one has and i've written about this
in the annual letter
uh uh but the uh
the value of float has gone down
dramatically because uh
everything is everything is off of
interest rates
and when you get to negative interest
rates
uh if a country can borrow negative
interest rates you get into something
that's kind of akin to the saint
petersburg paradox and those of you want
to go to search you can find some
interesting things on it but it becomes
infinite that
it's a it's a crazy uh
consequence of a bunch of abstract
mathematics that
where you get there but but you you
lose gravity entirely
uh and you know if you tell me that
that i'm gonna have to lend money to the
government minus two percent a year
and i'm talking nominal figures nothing
you know you're just telling me how i'll
go broke over time
[Laughter]
if i if i do that so it pushes you to do
other things and of course we've seen
it well we saw the rest of the world in
even more extreme fashion but
nobody paul samuelson
brilliant man nobody nobody thought you
could do this and
and we don't really know what the
consequences are
but we know there are consequences
obviously
what impact does the rise of so many new
specs have on berkshire's ability to
find and close new acquisitions
well it's a killer uh the specs
generally have to spend their money
in two years as i understand it so i
have to buy a business in two years
if you put a gun to my head and said you
got to buy a big business in two years
you know i'd buy one but
it wouldn't be much of one uh it's you
know we look and look
and and now there are i don't know how
many whether it's hundreds and
there's always been the pressure from
private equity funds i mean if you're
running money for somebody else and
you're getting paid a fee and you get
the upside and
and you don't have the downside you're
gonna buy something and uh
uh uh i i could tell you but i
i i had a very famous i had a call from
a very famous figure many years ago that
was involved in it and
i wanted to learn about reinsurance and
i said well i don't really think it's a
very good business and he said yeah
he says if i don't spend this money in
six months i've got to give it back to
the investors
so it you know it's a different equation
that you have if you're working with
other people's money where you get the
upside
and you have to give it back to them if
you don't do something and
frankly we're not competitive with that
yeah and that won't go on forever
but uh it's where the money is now and
wall street goes where the money is and
it
it does anything you know basically that
that works
and specs have been working for a while
and you stick your a famous name on it
you can
you can sell almost anything and it's
it's but
it's uh it's an exaggerated version of
what we've seen in
in kind of gambling done type market in
fact
i did have a quote from kane
this is this is probably the most famous
one of the most famous quotes in
in history because it really sums up the
problem of the fact we've got the
greatest markets the world could ever
imagine i mean imagine being able to
own parts of the biggest businesses in
the world and putting
billions of dollars in them and take it
out of you know
two days later i mean compared to farms
or apartment houses or
office buildings where it takes months
to close a deal
i mean the markets offer a chance to
participate and
invest in earning assets on a basis
that's
very very low cost and instantaneous
huge
all kinds of good things but it makes
its real money if they can get get the
gamblers to come in because they get
they provide more action and they're
willing to pay sillier fees and all
kinds of things so you have this
incredible uh
huge asset to you humanity
but it's it really makes us money when
people are doing
stupid things i mean that's where the
body really is and
keynes wrote this in 1930 in 1936 it
says 1939 on the slide but he wrote in
1936 in the general theory
that you know speculators may do no
no harm as bubbles on a steady stream of
enterprise
but the position is serious when
enterprise becomes the bubble on a
whirlpool of speculation
when the capital development of a
country becomes a byproduct
of the activities of a casino the job is
likely to build
ill done well the stock market
we've had a lot of people under the
casino in the last year you have
millions and billions of people have set
up accounts where they day trade where
they
where they're selling puts and calls
where they uh
i would say that you had the greatest
increase in the number
of gamblers essentially that and there's
nothing you know there's nothing wrong
with gambling and then
they got better odds than they've got if
they play the state lottery but
they've they've had cash in their pocket
they've had action
and they actually hadn't they don't have
a lot of good results and
and if they just bought stocks they'd do
fine and held them but
but the gambling impulse is very strong
in people worldwide and occasionally it
gets an enormous shove
uh and uh and conditions
lead to this place where more people are
entering the casino that are leaving
every day and it creates its own reality
for a while
and nobody tells you when the clock's
going to
strike 12 and it all turns to pumpkins
and mice but
the the
when the competition is playing with
other people's money
or what whether the and if they're
playing foolishly with their own money
but they
the big stuff is done with other
people's money
uh they're going to beat us i mean
we're not we're not that's a different
game and they've got more they've got a
lot of money
so we're not going to have much luck on
on acquisitions uh
while this sort of a period continues
but it's happened
before this is about as extreme as we've
seen it isn't it charlie
yes of course i call it fee driven by
in other words not buying because it's a
good investment they're buying it
because the advisor gets a fee
and of course the more that you get the
sillier your civilization is getting
and to some extent it's a moral failing
too
because the easy money made by things
like spax and total
return derivatives and so on and so on
you push that to excess it causes
horrible problems with the civil
civilization it reflects no credit on
the people that are doing it and no
credit on the regulators and voters that
allow it
so i i think we have a lot to be ashamed
of on
current conditions but it's where the
money is yeah but we still
but it's shameful what's going on it's
not just stupid it's shameful
it's not i don't regard it as shameful
on a lot of the people that
gamble i mean it
gambling is a very human instinct and
they've got money in their pocket
and they know somebody else has made
money who they don't think is any
smarter than they are
no i don't mind the poor fish that
gamble
i don't like the professionals that take
the suckers
says if you deem stock prices to be
overvalued or in a bubble
do you think it's best to keep your
money in cash while waiting for prices
to come down to a fair price
or would it be a better idea to invest
this money in some way while waiting
until stock prices are fair again and
then
sell the investment to buy the stocks
well charlie and i have had that
discussion on a lot of things
we bought some stocks we really don't
know that much about but
i'm not really comfortable doing that uh
we're used to shooting fish in a barrel
but that's gotten harder
we've we've got probably
10 to 15 percent uh of our total assets
in in cash beyond what i would like to
have just as
a way of protecting
the owners and the people that are
partners from ever having
having us ever get in a pickle you know
we we we
we really run first to make sure that
that
that uh we don't we don't want to lose
other people's money who will will stick
with us for years we can't help
somebody doesn't buys it today and sells
it tomorrow but wait we've got a
we got a real gene that pushes us in
that direction but
we've got more than we we've got
probably 70 or 80 billion uh something
like that maybe
that we'd love to put to work uh
but that's ten percent of our assets
roughly and then and and uh
uh we probably won't get we won't get a
chance to do it
uh under these conditions but conditions
change
very very very rapidly sometimes in
markets and
we do have people that would like to
join us
uh but the market option they have is
just
is too great for them and if they're
publicly traded i mean they they
basically can't
they they would have great difficulty
well then
making a deal with us because somebody
else would come along with using other
people's money
it's you know we may be unhappy about
the 70 billion but we're very happy
about the other 700 billion
so it's it's not like not like we should
complain
you said you bought some stocks that you
don't know a lot about what are they
well uh i i i will not get into naming
what zak said uh and it may be
maybe that they're somewhere that i
think i know about that i don't know
about but we
we have bought stocks where uh charlie
and i
i mean we know the business generally
but we don't have any
insights uh and they
are as a group if i had to
if told me i was gonna be shocked unless
i got the best result
i would rather own those stocks than the
treasury bills we own but on the other
hand we work with the quantities of
money
where uh if we put
50 billion of the things that i'm kind
of so-so about but that are better than
treasury bills
uh uh it doesn't i'm i'm not wildly
comfortable about that even though it
can be undone
it's selling 50 billion when it's really
attractive to buy something else
there's a lot of there's a lot of
slippage that can happen
in moving sums like that around so
that's something we talk about all the
time
they're good companies they're fine
companies but but
do we know something about those
companies or have a way of
evaluating that gives us an edge the
answer
i think but what do you feel about
charlie
we've talked about it a lot well of
course it's a lot harder
and and i think one consequence of this
present situation is that bernie sanders
has basically won
and that's because the with the
everything boomed up so high and
interest rates so low
what's going to happen is the millennial
generation is going to have a hell of a
time
getting rich compared to our generation
and so the difference between the rich
and the poor and the generation that's
rising is going to be a lot less so
bernie is one
he did it by accident but he won could
you and charlie please elaborate on the
higher order effect that these share
repurchases have on society
and their way of their way essentially
of distributing cash to the people that
want the cash when other
co-owners mostly want uh you to reinvest
and it's a savings vehicle if the four
of us
sitting at this table decided we'd buy a
few dairy queen franchises we form a
little company
and we all put in a million dollars or
something like that and we
buy the dairy queen franchises and
they're doing well
and three of the four of us want to keep
buying more dairy
queen franchises and we're not done
building
and saving for the future and uh
we're in the wealth creation business
and the fourth one says listen i'm
already i've gotten rich enough
i'd rather take some money out and uh
well there's only two ways to do it
we're gonna we can pay dividends all
four of us three of us
of whom don't want it and and and we can
uh we can repurchase the shares at a
fair price if it's just the four of us
we pick out a fair price and the fourth
one gets bought out
of his interest uh it
it i find it almost impossible to
believe some of the arguments that are
made that it's
it's terrible to me to repurchase
shares from a partner if they want to
get out of some something
and you're able to do it at a price
that's advantageous to the people that
are staying
and it's it helps slightly the
the person that wants out and and a
majority of the berkshire shuttle is a
great majority
we had a boat on dividends one time
we've got savers now that's partly
because we've advertised ourselves as
being that sort of a vehicle we've
created that something we've
stuck with it for 57 years and and
people look individuals a huge number
look at berkshire as something they're
they're gonna own
until they die now they may their
circumstances may change their needs may
change but
the savers generally keep saving we just
recently had
somebody that bothered came with us
60 years ago and billions of dollars and
that they just they didn't they weren't
saving exactly for their old days just
just was sort of built into them but
they like to do and now plants are
breeze will get a lot of money and so on
then
uh it's it's the most
what could be more logical than if if a
very small minority
of your holders want to get out and most
of them want to stay in and the person
wants to get out wants the money
you don't give the money to everybody
you give it to the one who wants it
and the and you do it at a price that
is beneficial the most part is on a
private deal you'd work out the fair
value
the market tells you the value in the
case of a publicly credit company
charlie got anything
well i i if you're re
purchasing stock just a bullet higher
it's deeply immoral but if you're
re-purchasing stock because it's a fair
thing to do
in the interest of your existing
shareholders it's a highly moral act
and the people who are criticizing it
are bonkers
if berkshire would switch its capital
return policy to dividends from buybacks
if the capital gains rate goes
up to 43.4 percent dividends would be
far more
tax advantaged for shareholders under
that scenario
yeah we had we we literally did have a
vote by our shareholders now we've got a
different group of shareholders and
a reit would have or you know
an mlp might have i mean there's
different people select what they go
into and people that go into spax are
hoping the stock goes up next week you
know i've been basically and
uh we've got a bunch of people that were
assembled over 55 years but they
they started with a base of people that
uh
it was a lifetime investment and and if
they wanted to cash out
they thought they'd get a fair price at
that time but they really didn't
they bought it with no intentions like
that so
we had a vote and it was something like
or something of the shares said they
don't want a dividend and
now that wouldn't be true at other
companies and it'd be crazy to be paying
a regular dividend like coca-cola
has done for many years and then all of
a sudden change the policy on
millions of people who have bought it
with one expectation in mind and trying
to change it into a different animal
but coca-cola isn't going to change the
berkshire and berkshire isn't going to
change the coca-cola we've got a
different group of owners
and and it will keep self-selecting
because people have a choice every day
but which do you want to
sort of thing do you want to be and
berkshire is a is a certain kind of
animal in that respect
if they jiggle on the tax laws that's
really got nothing to do with
the decision i mean with that we've got
a
very substantial majority of people that
that want us to reinvest the money and
and what they're more concerned about is
whether we find something to do with the
money
the 100 billion or something and
repurchasing shares is something that
helps them
uh in their they own a larger percentage
of berkshire as they go along and
they brought they they love to see us
buy another business but with
they don't mind us intensifying their
interest in the present business
what are your thoughts on the new
administration's capital gains corporate
tax and stepped-up basis tax increases
if if charlotte wants to answer that
i'll
i'll be glad to have him do it i i
long ago many times have said that that
i don't put my my
political opinions or anything in a
blind trust when i take this job but i
also don't speak for berkshire hathaway
i mean we've got uh people have very
different views on taxes and
and and uh uh
you know i've expressed some things in
the past but i don't like to speak on
behalf of
when i'm sitting in a berkshire hathaway
annual meeting presumably speaking for
berkshire i i don't really like to get
into
political questions generally i i don't
really think i should i
but i also think if somebody asked me
who i vote for before the last
election is a personal base i voted for
by now i but i don't i've never asked a
single employee of ours who they voted
for you know
anything of the sort of religion it just
it's it's
it's uh it it and it
i am not authorized to go around
signing my name as chairman of berkshire
hathaway then to
uh to proposals right if i write op-ed
pieces i do it as an individual i try to
make it clear
so i don't think i'll i don't want to
use the meeting to give a lot of views
about taxes charlie
no but
i think it's probably a mistake
to be basically
anti-capitalist i think capitalism is
what raises
gdp for everybody and so
and i have also a feeling that
benjamin franklin was right when he said
that it's hard for an empty sac to stand
upright
and to some extent the prosperity of
leading american institutions
helps them behave better now there are
exceptions
in promotional finance and so on but by
and large franklin was right
and so i i'm a little wary of
just constantly being mad at people
because they have a little more
money what are your thoughts on those
people leaving what keeps you in
california
well that's a very interesting question
i frequently said i wouldn't move across
the street to save my children
500 million in taxes and so
so i have that's that's my personal view
on the subject
but i do think it is stupid for states
to drive out their
wealthiest citizens the old people that
don't commit any crimes
they donate to the local charity it
who in the hell in the right mind would
drive out the rich people
i mean florida and places like that are
very shrewd in places like california
are being very stupid
it's contrary to the interests of the
state
how will a 25 to 28 percent corporate
tax rate affect berkshire's companies
well i don't think it would be the end
of the world we've adapted to the tax
rate whatever it is
yeah i i would say that if they raise
the tax rate
uh they're they're only the federal
government's owning a larger percentage
of business
but i'm not i'm not saying what the tax
rate is but we have a class a
stock and a class b stock the us
government owns what i call the class
a a stock that's a very special stock
they get a percentage of the earnings
but they don't own the assets and they
don't vote on who gets to run the place
or anything else
but if the government wants to take when
when i was first starting they used to
take 52 percent the federal government
did of
corporate profits and and they
they've got what would you pay to own
the government's class a
double a stock if if there was a public
issue
by the us treasury and they said this
vehicle
given a name like spak or something even
sexier but but
and all it will do is it owns
the future tax payments of berkshire
hathaway forever
and how much is that stock now worth and
it gets and it
it'll pay a big cash dividend and
they'll go up as we retain earnings and
build the company and everything else
it's worth more if it's if the tax rate
is 25
or 28 or 52 then at 21
they own a special stock and
and when
when people talk about how it all gets
passed through the customer and
everything in the utility business it
actually does it
that's a special case but it doesn't
it doesn't in most of our businesses i
mean it's just
it's a it's a corporate fiction when
they
put out statements about the fact that
this will be
terrible for all of you people who we
pay more taxes uh
it it hurts the berkshire shareholders
if rates are higher and that may be
quite appropriate but but to say
otherwise it's just
it doesn't make any sense i would love
to see the government actually issue
they could have i mean they could set up
a company just call it the
the berkshire hathaway tax company and
it would take all the taxes we paid
every year how much would they be able
to sell that asset for
they they talk about unfunded
obligations of the government
that's an unfo that's an unreported
asset of the federal government
they own part of berkshire and they get
to determine how much i mean it's
an interesting question in the owner's
manual a portion of your annual report
warren you state
on my death none of my stock will have
to be sold to take care of the cash
requests i've made or for taxes
with the recent biden proposal to treat
unrealized gains as sold and taxable at
death at a 43.4 percent rate
change the amount of stock required to
be sold for payment of taxes upon your
death
yeah well the tax law can be changed
tomorrow and i don't you know it can be
done a lot of different ways and it's
been
done a lot of different ways in the past
i can tell you
i can actually make a promise to society
that 99.7 percent of what i have when i
die will either go to philanthropy or to
the federal government
and the federal government can actually
determine the rules on that and
and no i would prefer
that it would go to philanthropy i think
it actually will accomplish more
utility if it goes
to be used by some smart people in
philanthropy than if it simply reduces
the federal debt
by a hundred billion dollars or
something when i i don't think it makes
a damn but a difference
you know whether the federal debt is 100
billion higher or lower it won't change
anything in the world
and at present days it doesn't really
save them anything because they can
borrow 100 billion it doesn't cost them
anything anyway
but that that condition won't prevail
but but i don't
i would not regard it just i'm just
talking about it
personally i'm not even advocating this
public policy but i wouldn't
if they took it they took it all you
know it would not bother me
i mean it i guarantee it won't bother
you yeah
charlie says you won't know but the uh
you know if you decide if if the
american democracy
decides that it's better to to take it
all i
which i don't think they will and i
don't think they should but nevertheless
you know so what you know and
i i would like to see it used to
accomplish the most
for humanity i mean and that means uh
having smart people uh properly
motivated
and more importantly not improperly
uh distribute it in a way and and who
knows what the hell it would be
10 20 30 or 40 years from now i do know
if it goes to government it basically
it reduces the national debt by that
amount i don't think it changes whether
they
change the minimum wage laws or does
anything else i just think
a little figure changes it'll be you
know it'll show up in the budget one day
you know
received from buffett you know x and
then and then
some huge figure beers down below i
don't think it really
so i i would prefer it be used privately
but
that's really up to the people of the
united states to decide through their
representatives mr jane what has covid19
taught us about systemic and correlated
risk and there
is there anything that we will do
differently from now on
yeah in the insurance business we often
think about pandemic risk as one of the
risk factors
that we need to cope with in our
business
having said that i think the big lesson
for us having gone through what we've
gone through recently
is that while we were aware of the fact
that pandemic risk is a risk factor
it was totally totally underpriced by
all of us in the industry
several of us thought it's an event that
will happen at most
100 years and even then those odds are
pretty high
so i think the big lesson for us is to
recalibrate and rethink about
what the return time is for something
like a pandemic risk
and separately we haven't yet
done a good enough job as an industry
i'm saying in terms of correlating the
risk and aggregating the risk and
making sure we can deal with the
aggregate numbers for example pandemic
risk has
obviously taken a lot taken
taken people's lives but then separately
a bunch of us
used to write something called event
cancellation or contingency policies
and in terms of pricing for the
contingency policies like the olympics
being cancelled
nbc would buy insurance for their rights
which might certainly be not worth much
and when pricing something like that
we would think in terms of earthquake
and risk and more recently terrorism
but we would never factor something like
what
portion of the price should come from
the pandemic exposure
so i think the industry will become a
lot more sophisticated in terms of
thinking through
what is the impact of pandemic risk
across the entire portfolio
as opposed to it just being localized to
one or two areas
as gene mentioned uh
people were throwing in i want an event
cancellation you know i mean lots of
people buy
insurance against the olympics being
cancelled or the united states not
participating
they try to think of all kinds of risks
because they had they have ad campaigns
based upon all
so there's a lot there's a lot of
cancellation insurance and it was
probably
uh underpriced the
implicit part of that premium that was
attributable to a pandemic risk i mean
it
you know bill gates gave a terrific talk
at ted
and five or six years ago and people
ignored it and and
uh it's very interesting because this
isn't the worst case what we've
what we've seen and and yet it's it's
staggering
in terms of what has happened and
and people that wrote insurance
uh that
they they they may have found out
sometimes that they were covering things
they didn't want to
didn't even intend to cover maybe the
insurance
didn't didn't think they were buying but
nevertheless
after the event occurs that they get
very inventive and coming after them
there are certain risks too that are
just too big the nuclear risk
for example i mean the federal
government is
very early on they recognize that the
private insurance industry
uh they can't handle a uh
the risk involved in the financial risk
that would be involved in terms of a
massive uh
nuclear strike or something like that so
it's
the pandemics
the wording will be much more careful in
in future policies on
on trying to define it very precisely
and incidentally i mean
the way the cases have come so far and
in the united
kingdom uh i mean and i think there was
one particular insurer i mean that
the cases are coming down much tougher
on insurers and
in the united states i mean the the
policies were just
written differently you don't you don't
get insurance against something you
don't buy against it
for and generally the the court
decisions have
have come down favorable to insurers and
and and at berkshire it just so happens
we are not a big
big player but that's uh in
commercial mobile peril which might be
where
uh it is not a huge factor for berkshire
what's your best estimate of berkshire's
insurance claim exposure from the covet
19 pandemic
well in terms of reserves starting from
last year to the end of the first
quarter this year
we have put up a billion six and change
in terms of reserves now what that
doesn't take into account
is some of the frequency benefit because
of covet 19
that results because of fewer accidents
and geico's had a huge tailwind
because of that but in terms of
what the insurance operations
collectively are going to be writing
checks for
that number as of now is about a billion
six
and my guess is that will probably grow
because if you look upon it
the industry as a whole has reserved
we've reserved 1.6 as i mentioned
about 25 to 30 billion dollars
for covet 19 as of now if you believe
the pundits in the industry they will
tell you that number is probably going
to be closer to 100 billion
so there's another about 70 75 billion
dollars of covert 19 losses
that need to flow through insurance
industries balance sheet and
income statement our number therefore
of 1.6 that we have as of now is going
to be a lot lot higher
but it's not something that we cannot
manage completely yeah we will not be
in this top five right payers of
my guess of insurance claims even though
we're here
it's uh and we we write a
much smaller amount of both life
insurance
and annuities actually and you know in
the end we get
we had more life insurance crimes but
but the annuities are not going to last
more people will have died that would
have otherwise got payments under
annuities
it cuts a lot of ways it's it's it's a
you know one of the great human
catastrophes of all time but it is not
uh it's not that big insurance and i
would say this
if the insurance industry thinks they're
going to lose 100 billion
100 billion ought to be up on their
books now i mean the idea of feeding in
losses you've got a liability and
and our goal is not
our goal is to have put up the liability
when it when it when
we think it's happened and then uh
if we should not be at a billion six i
would say this if we really
if we really think we're going to have
some proportional share of 100 billion
but uh uh
well that's an upset on that what does
the
combination of kansas city southern with
either canadian pacific or canadian
national mean to bnsf
in terms of competition and do you think
the synergies of the merger will justify
the multiple paid
it's obviously a transaction
we followed very closely with both
canadian national and canadian pacific
bidding to purchase kansas city southern
either of those companies acquiring
kansas city southern will have an impact
on
bnsf we
what they're basically proposing is to
create a
north-south railway that goes from
canada into mexico
we do have a strong presence in mexico
not as strong as
as some of our competition but we would
feel competition there so
uh we'll follow that transaction very
closely
as it goes before the surface
transportation board
the standard that will be applied is
that competition has to be
protected or enhanced so that's our
opportunity to protect our franchise on
behalf of
our customers so we we move intermodal
business both in and out of there on
behalf of certain customers
we'll want to protect uh the rights of
our customers there so we'll be active
in in the approval process but there's
no
question in the end it impacts our
franchise warren
yeah it it
it's not huge but uh
it affects both the union pacific and
the nsf to a small degree a relatively
small degree and but that's
that's not really the worry of the
surface transportation board their job
is to do what's best
uh for the the shippers
and and uh uh
in terms of the price that's being paid
uh
you know uh
but like you say when if you can borrow
all the money enough for nothing yeah
you know
it doesn't make much difference to
people and and this would not be being
paid under a different interest rate
environment i mean it's very simple uh
but
uh it it would make uh
there's no magic to the kansas city
southern it's got a i think
their deal with mexico ends in 2047
and that i mean it's it's uh you know
it it will uh
it's the number of carloads carried
everything they're not gonna change that
much
uh uh uh but
it is kind of interesting there's only
there's there's
two major canadian what they call class
one railroads and there's
there's five in the united states and
and
uh uh this will result you know in
essentially three of the units uh
being canadian poor being u.s which is
not the way you normally think
of the way the development of the
railroad system would work in the united
states but
it's you know we've talked about it
plenty and
and uh uh
cp or either canadian pacific or
canadian national
was very likely to get i think surface
transportation board but
voted for one didn't they the other day
didn't get my credit card
they voted on an initial trust structure
that they had to approve for uh
canadian pacific and that was a four to
one vote as you noted warren so
they're moving forward with the
evaluation of it yeah and normally
railroad deals are very long take a long
time for them to evaluate
but in this case i think they have two
two opposing
trust proposals and in effect
uh by making a if they make a quick
decision on the
which trust proposal will they allow i
don't i don't say i allow two proposals
exactly so
it may be a very accelerated decision i
don't know but uh
it's up to the surface transportation
board to do what's what's best for
what their obligation is to the country
to do
on that do you think the valuation that
they're paying
is worth it in a very very mild way i
mean
everybody's kind of played making deals
with different railroads
you know ever since i've been in the
railroad business
so uh you know we've talked about it
we went cp when when when
when uh was
hunter sooner that you know came after
was it
that kind of led the way and uh uh
you know we looked at buying cp i mean
everybody looks at everything and uh uh
we would not pay this price and it
implies a price for
the nsf that's even higher than what the
up is selling for
uh but
you know it's kind of play money to some
degree i mean when when interest rates
are this low and
and i'm sure from the standpoint of both
the
cp and cn there's there's only one kc
southern and
they're not going to get a chance to
expand they're not going to buy us
they're going to buy the up and
and the juices flow and and uh the
prices go up and
and everybody has somebody else's money
yeah it's somebody else's money and
you're going to retire
in five or 10 years and people are not
going to remember what you pay but
they're going to remember whether you
built a larger system
and the investment bankers are cheering
you on at every move you know
they're saying you could pay more and
this is the you know they're moving the
figures around the spreadsheets are out
and
the fees are flowing in this year's
chairman letter you discussed that you
made a mistake in 2016 when calculating
precision cast parts average amount of
future earnings which resulted in
berkshire overpaying to acquire it
it appears that precision's earnings
declined substantially in 2020 because
of the pandemic and the effective
airline and travel industry
what calculations could you have made in
2016 that might have altered your
decision to acquire it and secondly are
the problems precision is currently
facing
larger than the pandemic berkshire
didn't make the mistake i made the
mistake incidentally
uh the no i when any time we look at
buying a business
we're evaluating the competitive
strengths of the business the price we
have to pay the management we
get everything and and and we didn't
make a mistake on the management but
in terms of the earning power
on average and
you know when when
boeing has troubles with the max well
that's that's a probability i mean
anytime any
any customer is a big i mean all kinds
of things can happen
and and we have seen some of those
things happen
and and therefore
i paid too much in relation to average
earnings
it's a terrific company and and and uh
you know it
it's i'm happy happy with the management
and everything and
but ge doesn't need as many engines as
we thought
would need and they and that they they
get into the power business and
a variety of things and we knew though
they're in their businesses but
we did not think those businesses would
necessarily be in
something close to a depression when
other businesses
are that we bought end up doing
sometimes is doing
better than we think uh but we will
we'll continue making mistakes i mean
and i shouldn't say we will i will
uh but even these other restaurants will
help
and and uh and well you know
we've we've got some wonderful deals and
some terrible deals and
and uh the nice thing about it is as i
pointed out
this doesn't really precise apply in the
case of precision precisely but
when we're disappointed in a business it
usually becomes a smaller and smaller
percentage of our business just by the
nature of things because it isn't going
any place
and when we get a successful business
like a geico or something of the sort of
geico's doing they're they're doing 15
times as much business as when we bought
control in 1998 they they become a
proportionally
much more important part of our mix so
you really get through just natural
forces you get
more of your money in the things that
have developed more favorably than you
thought
you actually end up getting a greater
concentration
in the ones that work out it's not like
charlie would say it's not like having
children i mean
the the ones that the bad would cause
you war problems but
but the uh but in this in the in the
children of businesses
the small ones kind of by the way we
started with three businesses charlie
and i and
and uh and berkshire was textiles
diversified retailing was a department
store and training stamps were
blue chips business and those were the
three companies we put together and
all three of the original businesses
failed which sort of gets me in terms of
the
people that are worried about about
don't we know that
that coal is going to be phased out over
time of course we don't goals
you know but that that doesn't mean
we're going to be phased out over time i
mean that that
every business has some things to think
about about that way
the biggest danger they have that
section in the perspective is called
what do they call that and uh about
certain risk factors but risk factors
yeah
the number one risk factor you never see
it the number one risk factor
is that this business gets the wrong
management and you get a guy
or a woman in charge of it that are
they're personable the directors like
them
they don't know what they're doing but
they they they know how to put on an
appearance
that's the biggest single danger that a
businessman and then and that that
person stays and runs it for 10 or 15
years and
either stays in the textile business the
department store business and expands
and uh you know i've looked at a lot of
businesses and
that's what caused the number one
problem and it isn't the kind of thing
where they list them all because the
lawyers tell them to list them now that
the crypto
market overall is valued at two trillion
dollars do you still consider cryptos as
worthless
artificial gold
i knew there'd be a question on bitcoin
or
i had and uh i thought to myself well
i've watched these politicians dodge
questions all the time you know
and and and uh i always find it kind of
disgusting when they do it but
the truth is i'm going to dodge that
question because the
we probably got hundreds of thousands of
people watching this
that own bitcoin and we've probably got
two people that are short so we got a
choice of making 400
000 people mad at us and unhappy and
or making two people happy and that's
just a
dumb equation so i i thought about we
had a governor one time in
in uh nebraska and a long time ago but
uh he would get a tough question you
know what do you think about property
taxes or
you know what should we do about schools
and and he'd look right at the person
he'd say
i'm all right on that one and then you
just walk off well
i'm all right on that one and maybe
we'll see how charlie is
well those who know me well
are just waving the red flag of the bull
of course i hate the bitcoin success
and i don't welcome a currency that's so
useful and
to kidnappers and extortionists and so
forth
nor do i like just shuffling out a few
extra
billions and billions and billions of
dollars to somebody who just invented a
new
financial product out of thin air
so
i think i should say modestly that i
think the whole
damn development is disgusting and
contrary to the interests of
civilization and i'll let leave the
criticism
to others i'm all right on that one
elon musk has stated that berkshire
hathaway's energy proposal for texas
spending more than nine billion dollars
for new generating capacity is wrong
instead mr musk argues that load
balancing using battery storage as the
appropriate course of action
can you explain why the bag proposal is
the better course of action for governor
abbott in the state of texas
specifically what amount of savings can
the citizens of texas suspect above and
beyond what mr musk is proposing
obviously there is a very unfortunate
event in texas in
in february and it basically lasted four
days many
lives were lost the economic damage was
significant texas has highlighted that
anywhere from 80
80 to 130 billion dollars and
incurred losses over that period of time
and i i think when you look at the power
sector it fundamentally let the citizens
down it didn't perform as
as they expected and and then
when it did perform it was extremely
expensive
uh they they incurred billions and
billions of dollars of
of energy costs versus a multiple
of of of basically 10 times what they
paid
they paid 10 times in energy costs over
those four days what they paid
in in the past year so a very
substantial event for
for texas we've we've gone to texas with
what we believe
is a good solution uh we spent a lot of
time pulling it together
understanding the the fundamental issues
around it
and our proposal is really based upon
the fact that
the the health and welfare of of texans
were at risk and
and we needed to have
effectively an insurance policy in place
for them that if they needed the power
on very short notice it would be able to
be dispatched and it would be there for
the the four days we're actually
proposing it could be there for
for seven days and the and the final
fundamental concept of our proposal has
always been
if there's a better proposal that's
brought forward
we've accomplished our mission we've
just been really there to
uh it's the it's the best proposal or
option we could come up with and
obviously if texas or or
elon or someone else comes up with a
better proposition
we've always said texas you should
pursue it
we strongly believe right now we have a
what remains is a very good
good proposal for texas and it'll
continue to be
discussed and evaluated the big
difference between a
battery proposal and our proposal
is that we will have power that can be
generated continuously
for seven consistent days
where if you went to a battery solution
you may release that power that's been
stored for four hours
but we're talking four days of of a
problem
not four hours and and it's just a
completely different cost equation and
and solutions so very proud that our
teams brought forward uh
what i thought was a very unique
solution we've worked
hard with our our suppliers and
and peter q and sons to put together
what we believe is a
a firm cost that uh that can also be
delivered by november of 23.
so again we put a firm date on uh it
won't be ready next winter unfortunately
it won't be ready this summer
but it's uh it's a valuable solution
and one that uh we hope at least leads
to the right discussion and the right
long-term solution for the state
yeah and we're we're also willing to put
up four billion dollars
that if we don't deliver when we say
we're going to deliver
uh we'll we'll pay it as as a penalty
basically and and
uh uh
but you know we went to keyword we went
to general electric and said you know
how long can we get turbines and
alfred
you know if you're gonna be prepared for
it you have to start at the point fairly
soon and you have inflation going on and
and okay was not going to change things
on us in a month we don't try to get
the contracts all written out but we
they had a hundred people working on it
yeah they had hundreds working yeah and
everything you know and ge is
cooperative and everything
but doesn't mean we have the best
solution we just know what we can do
and and if anybody can do it faster they
can do it cheaper
you know whatever that's terrific but
they should have something to lose or if
they don't do it i mean
and we will back our problems up by four
billion dollars which
uh you know and and we won't have any
ranking causes in there that
that if this happens or that happens we
don't pay well so
but we won't be able to do that a year
from now i mean we can do it a year from
now with the cost then from what they
are then and then it'll be a year
further out
we we want to texas is a terrific place
to do business we do a lot of business
there and
it's where being us
and it's it's a great place and uh and
this was
out of the blue but
one way or another the nature of
of of utility business is that
you've got to you have to be prepared
for something that probably isn't going
to happen
and you know you don't want to say it's
a well it's a 130-year event you know
and then
and people die i mean it's so uh
you want you want a margin of safety in
it and
and we've got one solution and other
people may have other solutions and
and we will we will cheer when a
solution is re
reached of any kind and we will share a
little louder if it's ours
suppose the hypothetical situation
arises where warren buffett calls you on
the phone to tell you that elon musk has
contacted him about writing an insurance
policy on his proposed mission to
and subsequent colonization of mars
specifically he wants insurance to
ensure a spacex heavy rocket
capsule payload and human capital would
you underwrite any portion of a venture
like that
this is an easy one no thank you i'll
pass
well i would say would depend on the
premium
and and i would say that that i would
probably
uh have a somewhat different rate if
elon was on board or not on board i mean
you know
it makes a difference i mean if somebody
if somebody's asking you to insure
something you know
so i would that's called getting skin in
the game and
you know
but in general i would be very concerned
about
writing an insurance policy where elon
musk is on the other side
okay um tell elon to call me and set up
a jeep
[Laughter]
you mentioned that the best investment
results come from the companies that
require minimum
assets to conduct high margin businesses
in today's world many of these companies
tend to be software driven businesses
while berkshire has avoided investing in
high growth technology companies in the
past this appears to be slowly changing
with your investments
in apple and snowflake as shareholders
should we expect that high margin
businesses will begin to constitute a
larger proportion of berkshire's
investment portfolio over time
particularly as todd and ted take on
larger roles in the investment decision
process
we've always known that the dream
business is the one that takes very
little capital and grows a lot
and and apple and google and microsoft
and
facebook are terrific examples of that i
mean
apple has 37 billion dollars in property
plant equipment
you know berkshire has 170 billion or
something like that and
they're going to make a lot more money
than we do they're they're in better
business it's a
much better business than we have and so
in microsoft business is a way better
business we have google's business is
way better business uh so
it we've always looked we've known that
a long time we found that out with
seized candy in 1972 i mean
sees candy just doesn't require that
much capital it
it doesn't have you know it has it has
obviously a couple of manufacturing
plants they call them kitchens
and uh but it it it doesn't have a
big it doesn't have big inventories
except very seasonally very for a short
period it doesn't have a lot of
receivables so
they're you know those are the kind of
businesses they're the best businesses
but they command the best prices too and
there aren't that many of them and they
don't always stay that way
so uh we're looking for them all the
time and we've gotta
we've got a few that are pretty darn
good but but uh
we don't have anything as big as the as
the big guy but that's what everybody's
looking for
that's that's what capitalism is about
people getting a return on capital
and and the way you get it
is having something that doesn't take
too much capital i mean if you have to
really
put out tons and tons of capital utility
business that way
it's not a it's not a super high return
business you just have to put out a lot
of capital you get a return on that
capital
but but you don't get you don't get
fabulous return you don't get google
like returns it you know or anything
remotely close to it uh you know we're
proposing a
return in the in the uh
transaction with the proposition with
taxes i think it's a 9.3 percent
yeah and you know that but if you look
at the return on most american
businesses on
net tangible assets it's a lot higher
than 9.3
but but they aren't utility businesses
either
we are grateful for their efforts but
todd and ted are still not made
available to shareholders at the annual
meeting each year
given their growing importance to the
firm can you discuss this policy and
whether we can expect to hear from them
more in the coming years
they're both absolutely terrific and
that's one reason i don't want people
quizzing them on stocks
they they are assets of berkshire and
just
there's no reason for them to be out
educating other people on how to compete
with us
uh and it wouldn't it it
it always seems so silly that people
expect
they don't expect you to they don't
expect murk or advisor or something to
tell them exactly what their scientists
are working on you know
where they stand or where the failures
have been so they can eliminate those
yeah and and you know that
the the if you've got
talent that knows how to evaluate
business and and those two fellows have
been
they've gone far beyond that uh they've
terrific assets and they
they love they love berkshire and they
work extraordinary hours
but but we don't really want them
going around with people asking them
questions about why you like this
industry better than that industry or
anything of the sort
what are your current thoughts on china
and whether the communist leaders will
allow businesses with strong leadership
to flourish in decades to come
well i think that that the chinese
government will allow
businesses to flourish it was a
one of the most remarkable things that
ever happened in the history of the
world when a bunch of committed
communists
just looked at the prosperity of places
like singapore
and said the hell with this we're not
going to stay here in poverty we're
going to copy
what works and they changed communism
they just accepted adam smith
and added it to their communism and now
we have communism
with chinese characteristics which is
china with a free market with a bunch of
billionaires and so forth and they made
that shift they deserve a lot of credit
warren and i are not quite as good at
that as changing our minds
in many cases and
and that was a remarkable change coming
from such a place
and of course it's worked like
gangbusters it has enormous
growth in the average income of the
average chinese they've lifted
800 million people out of poverty
fast and there's never anything like the
history of the world so my hat is off to
the chinese
and i think they will continue to allow
people to make money
they've learned it works the chinese i
love what the guy said in the first
place i don't care whether the cat is
black and white as long as it catches
mice
that's my kind of talk
in that list of the 20 most valuable
companies that just
three are chinese now if you if you're
looking out 30 years
you know mama do you think it'll be
chinese my guess is more but
uh but i don't think i don't think it'll
top the united states
but who knows it's
it's amazing what what has been
accomplished and and
yeah really amazing and they found what
works i mean there's nothing like
finding something works
in order to sort of reinforce ideas over
time and
we'll see what happens but i would bet
there will be more than
three but i will bet the united states
has more than china has to
president joe biden's 1.9 trillion
dollar american rescue stimulus plan
this is the least responsible
macroeconomic policy we've had in the
last 40 years
your thoughts you're asking me on that
yeah he didn't write to who so i asked
anybody on the stage i would
i would say that larry's been reading
his uncle's book
which was paul samuelson but larry is a
very very very smart uh fellow and he's
laying out
possibilities which uh
actually now have probably been voiced a
little more even since
that that march 19th uh
uh uh whatever date it was that he
made that it
you can't just do one thing in economics
and and and uh
if we really could shovel
out more and more debt and the carrying
cost turned out to be something very
good
people thought japan couldn't do what
they've done but they you know and
they that uh used to be called the
widowmaker and
around solomon and and people were
were shorting uh japanese bonds but
uh it
the the answer is we don't know but
larry's view
uh is an important view and it's just as
good as
in my probably the the view on the other
side
might be we we don't know what happens
from from
the present policies we do know as
as jay paul said the other day the idea
that a hundred percent of
gdp was some terribly dangerous level
for g
uh uh in terms of uh debt
and it that that doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense now and that used to
be kind of
kind of uh accepted wisdom uh we've
learned that a lot of things we thought
before
weren't true but we haven't learned yet
is whether what we're doing now
is true and and we and the best thing to
do is recognize you don't know and and
proceed in a way where you get a decent
result
no matter what happens and that's what
we try and do at berkshire hathaway
we do not think we can make money by
making macro academic
economic predictions we do think we can
we do think we can pretty darn be pretty
darn sure we'll get a reasonable result
uh under policies that will not maximize
result if we could do that sort of thing
it's not at all clear whether larry is
right or wrong
and he's a smart man he is a smart man
and and it's courageous
into raising it to her he's actually the
only one talking that way
which i admire by the way yeah it
guarantees he won't get a position in
the administration yes
well that's one of the reasons i admire
him yeah and it
not that there was anything wrong with
having a position in the administration
but i think
people who kind of tell the way they
think it is i like it
could you please explain why you decided
to exit most of your bank stocks
in 2020 except for bank of america and
what's your view on the future of the
banking industry
i like banks generally i just didn't
like the proportion we had it compared
to the
possible risk if we if we got bad
results that
did not so far we haven't gotten so i i
just
and i we were over
10 percent of bank of america there's
it's a real pain in the neck both to the
bank and
more of the banks than us if we go over
10 percent there's just all
and uh i like the bank of america i mean
i
and i like brian moynihan very much and
and i like
the banking business fine so we
took that up but we took the overall
bank position down we didn't want to go
above 10 and any others
and we did want to increase the b of a
position but but we overall
didn't want as much uh in banks as
as we have we like the banking business
is way better than it was
in the united states in 10 or 15 years
ago the banking business around the
world
uh in various places what might might
worry me but uh
we our banks are in far far better shape
than
10 or 15 years ago but when things froze
for a short period of time the biggest
thing the banks had
going for is that the federal reserve
was buying them and federal reserve is
not
they're not behind berkshire it's up to
us to take care of ourselves
you recently purchased a large stake in
verizon for educational purposes could
you please explain your thinking behind
this investment
in general many people see telecoms as
dumb pipes that have to spend heavily on
capex building out the 5g infrastructure
only for the other tech companies to
take advantage and capture most of the
value created from the infrastructure
like facebook
uber i think he's analyzed the situation
well but i we are not
in a uh in the business of explaining
own a stock which we either might buy
more of or sell or who knows what so
uh he's on his own but he sounds like he
he's very capable of thinking it through
very well himself
as berkshire's board already discussed
what would happen to the company over
the long term if berkshire was to be
prevented from acquiring controlled
businesses
we don't discuss that as a specific but
the board is very very very familiar
with
what berkshire does why they do it
you know what how we think in deploying
capital
uh but we could you know
everybody knows that if you change the
anti-trust laws it can change things for
berkshire if they change the tax laws
and change things for berkshire
you know there's a lot of things and and
we can
we could spend hours discussing them but
in the end
you know is it is it a 22.3
risk that you know something changes
it's a good way to fill the time at
board meetings and if you're getting
three or four hundred thousand dollars a
year as a board director you might
you might want to spend your time doing
that but we really don't focus on that
the main thing about berkshire is how
they preserve
the culture how do you make sure that if
you get the wrong person as a ceo you
can do something about it that's the
biggest risk
board has is if you pick the wrong ceo
and i've been on 20
boards and it's happened more than once
and it's
sometimes it's a terrible problem to get
rid of them you know years go by
and and uh you know
the dissident comes in it's one thing
but if you just sit there and you
collect your three or four hundred
thousand a year
and and the chief executive keeps
proposing you get increased
time to time and it's worse yet if he's
if he's a nice person
uh you know doing his best and
we're not going to spend a lot of time
we may do it on a personal basis but
we're not going to take a lot of people
and
we want them to know more about what's
going on with bnsf and how katie's doing
and whether this whether the
kcs thing can injure us in any
material way and so on and we really
don't
except maybe on a private side things we
we don't we don't
start talking about you know what the
effects will be in
2050 if this projection or that
projection is met
why does warren say berkshire's ability
to ensure enormous risk quickly
is a less valuable asset than it used to
be because the demand is less
i mean basically on that it
if you take a period like happened after
9 11
uh i remember i
i may be wrong in the details of this
but cathay pacific
for example they couldn't land in hong
kong as i remember unless they had
an insurance policy by monday of the
following week well
we can do it uh i mean she calls me up
and and
he thinks of a price and i think of a
price and then
and but but we could we can do it and we
can take the loss if it happens
they call us on the sears tower i think
back then after that you know nobody
knew
uh uh they they didn't know whether
you know bombs are might be placed all
over that
so then they wanted more insurance all
of a sudden and
we gave them a price that thing that
that sort of an environment
hasn't really persisted i mean there
were times i think perhaps aig
when aunt greenberg was there he would
do the same thing uh
but there weren't 10 or 20 people out
there and they needed big limits
in some cases and we were good for it
and they knew that if they bought the
insurance and
it happened we'd write a check and it
would clear
in addition to the demand side the
supply side has become a lot more
competitive as well a lot of people who
can put up big limits
not as much as we do but they can
syndicate a program and put up a billion
dollar
very easily so that competitive
advantage we had
we still have but it's no longer as big
a deal as it used to be
warren charlie and greg's views on how
kraft heinz has performed over the last
12 months compared to the disappointing
performance pre-coveted
i think that greg's on the board so he
i don't i don't know that we're in a
position to give advice on
on craft heinz we do you know we entered
a
uh in effect a semi-formal
partnership with with 3g many years ago
when it was just the hinds deal
and then went on to the choir craft with
our partners and
and uh they've
done more than they hold up their share
of thing
and we we do what we said we do
going in which is to be uh a financial
partner and they're more of the
operating partner although we
participate
to a degree in the in any big decisions
and and
they would listen to us but but we're
not we're not making any
uh in terms of crafting stock that's
that's up to somebody else to evaluate
i think we're very comfortable with the
fact that they put a very
a strong manager in place in miguel and
and he's put a very good team in place
at craft heinz so we're pleased with
the leadership and management team in in
place they're very focused on
how they're executing as they've gone
forward and and rationalizing their
capital structure
and managing down their their debt
structure so very pleased with the path
forward with the with the existing
yeah we feel better about the the
one of the this is a more general
subject but uh one of the
subjects i might write about in one of
the future annual reports is
is the problems caused by the myths that
people have about their own organization
and i've seen that so many times in
various forms
and to some extent the problem has
become accentuated in the last 20 or 30
years
because the ceo often
and works with the investor relations
and they say well we have to have
constant contact with the
with the uh analyst community and of
course so they go on every couple of
months and they repeat
certain things about their company and
it becomes part of uh
sort of the catechism and nobody's going
to go on
two months after the ceo has said one
thing and say well actually that really
isn't the way
they're they're not going to contradict
themselves or change course
and so if you get these myths uh and
they can occur in a lot of different
ways i can give a lot of examples which
i won't do as i
tell my friends in corporate america i'm
really not going to squeal on them but
but there's there's a lot of mythology
that gets
handed down from one ceo to the next
can the succeeding ceo say the guy that
picked him
you know was on the wrong course or he's
been telling you something that isn't
really quite true
he can't do it you know and then he
starts repeating it
and it's it leads to enormous errors
uh but it's it's hard to tell the story
without giving examples that i don't
like to give examples
so we'll see whether i write about it
sometimes charlie you've probably got
some thoughts that we've
he's been a he's had a ringside seated a
lot of
uh he's been on boards and i haven't
been on i mean it doesn't just extend
the business
it goes beyond that and education and
and and
do well a lot of areas what's really
interesting is the way
you prattle out all the time you're
pounding back in even if it's wrong
and so one of my favorite
remarks in the history of human remarks
was by sir cedric
hartwick who is a great british actor
and he said
i have been a great actor for so long
that i no longer know what i truly think
on any subject
and i think that happens to a lot of
people
and it happens to virtually every
politician
and it gets embedded and incorporated
it's embedded and and the trouble is
now the ceos speak out so often so they
if they've got some crazy thing that
they're saying about their company
and they keep repeating it the
subordinates aren't going to contradict
the six you know it
it and and they said they just believe
it after a while
and uh it it's dangerous
yeah and of course the young people get
these ideas after their liberal
educations
think that god has given them direct
insights and
they're just as crazy as the politician
yeah there's some old people that have
yeah
well the old people are already crazy
but
they're going to die sooner so we have
our old we have our oldest
insanities the new insanities are the
young
the young get could you tell us what
happened to the joint venture between
berkshire jp morgan and amazon to
investigate what could be done about the
current state of medic
medical health care in the united states
we learned a lot about the
the difficulty of changing around an
industry that's 17
of gdp we accomplished a
a lesser objective which was probably
more important to us even than either jp
morgan or
amazon because we knew less about our
own system
than they did they knew that they were
more centralized operations so we
we got some benefits in the sense that
we looked at 60 or 70 different
operations we had presently and and
and that was that's one case where a
certain amount of centralization
at least in certain aspects of it could
save real money i mean we we found
inefficiencies
uh and like i say we probably
saved more than the other two partners
because they knew they knew their
situation better we found some dumb
things we were doing
uh so we got our money's worth but in
terms of the big
of the big picture of changing something
that so many people have a vested
interest in doing
and there's one additional factor to it
which is really interesting
there's an ingenious aspect to it it
goes back to a fellow named
which didn't have any direct connection
but beardsley rummel and uh
nobody's ever heard of beardsley rumble
but bridgeley rumble in 1941
came up with the idea of the withholding
tax so people
instead of april 15th having to write a
check and think how much they hated
their politicians and aided the
government and everything else
they actually looked at as kind of a
christmas club and there were
overpayments involved and they actually
got a check when the
final payment came to so when you aren't
writing the check
yourself you know you you may know that
the health benefit from your company
is worth ten thousand dollars a year to
you or fifteen thousand it may cost them
that much
but it may cost the company that much
but you don't see it
so the company pays it and
most of the people in that waiting room
sitting next to me when they
they are not sitting there thinking
about whether i can
afford to do this you know or what's
this going to do they
they're generally under some kind of a
plan not always obviously
but they don't think that if the company
wasn't
paying them that they could pay them to
that in additional compensation but
of course the weird system is the
company gets a deduction if they pay it
but
if you pay it yourself on a policy i
don't believe you get a deduction of
the uh so it's
it's something that's most of the people
are not seeing as a cost to them and
they
they like that pretty well no kidding
yeah well but that's that's true the
federal income tax i mean
it was an active genius from the
standpoint of the government to go to a
withholding system and
and if you didn't just think of how many
people on april 15th would
have to sit down and write a pretty
good-sized check and
and they'd be mad they wouldn't like it
and they don't feel it now
uh so we
we were up that you know that's an
obvious point
but you also people like their doctor
in general and they don't like the fact
that it's 17
of gdp but one is just kind of a you
know
amorphous sort of thing and the other is
very very real to them and
the most prestigious people in the
community or on the hospital boards and
a lot of people that that are fairly
happy with the system so
so we did not make inroads on that
and we are paying 17 percent
of gdp for health care and no major
country is
more than 11 and in the pandemic
you know we've had a death rate or a
death total
as the percentage of population that's
way higher than the rest of the world
not
every single country but way higher so
it
uh you know we've laid out more money
and
gotten a poorer result in terms of this
particular pandemic in terms of deaths
per capita now that may not turn out to
be the
warren even though you shot it and
missed
you were at least shooting at an
elephant the cost of healthcare
in singapore is 20 of what it is in the
united states
and their medical system works better so
you were shooting at a
huge elephant but as you found out
it's very hard to people to get very
enthusiastic about losing part of their
income yeah no i
good wonderful phrase the tapeworm
i'll have to copy that well i wasn't
afraid we were looking but
is there a point at which berkshire
becomes too large to manage
and should we have any concern over the
lack of information from most of
berkshire's companies
is there a time that could come when
berkshire's too large and complex
well it's too large to do certain things
that's for sure i mean we you know it's
not
we can't spend our time looking for 100
million dollar acquisitions uh
but uh
we have a wonderful company in fort
worth and
and we had a marvelous man running it
and he died recently uh
but uh he read it
he sold it to me 15 years ago and he
just basically ran it you know
and i couldn't i couldn't find my way to
the company
we've got we've got this terrific
company that uh
uh makes recreational vehicles at all
car
based in elkhorn indiana and we bought
it 15 years ago i've never been there
you know maybe there's some kind of
closet just making up numbers to send to
me everybody but
i i i feel i understand the business
pretty well but i've never seen it
and the fellow that runs it likes
running it
and he likes me keeping my nose out of
it and he'll let greg get a little more
than
let me because
but it's we've got a system that will
work
with wonderful businesses and wonderful
managers and
it's up to us to define them but it's
also us
to nurture them when we find them and
and
uh if you get somebody like paul andrews
who ran tti
and who built it from nothing absolutely
nothing nobody ever heard of him
and the earnings of
octupled uh during the
period that he ran it for us and
he was happy employees were happy he was
a wonderful man
we were happy and i would call him at
the end of the year and i'd say
paul you know this place is you're
shooting the lights out everything and
you should take a raise and he said uh
her baldness
they'd say well we'll talk about that
next year warren i mean he did he just
loved
he loved the business i loved berkshire
he loved the business and
and i wasn't going to add anything uh
by having him fill out a bunch of
reports about how much how much
he's using in a way of of carbon or
anything
you know it's just it's ridiculous to
think of a guy
like paul andrews behaving in an
anti-social manner or anything of the
sort
and uh we'd love to have more of those
and obviously if we get bigger
they get harder to buy but we've got a
number in the place
and and i don't think we bought our last
one over time but i i certainly don't
see anything
in the near future at all but we're but
we're intensifying our
interest a little bit in the ones we
have by repurchasing shares so our
shareholders own more of those companies
uh every year while we're
assuming we're repurchasing shares which
is price sensitive
charlie yeah i don't think we're getting
too big to manage because
we're different from frankly every other
big corporation
in the united states and that we are so
excessively
decentralized we have decentralized so
much
and we have so much authority in the
subsidiaries
that we can keep doing it for a long
long time
as long as it keeps working and i would
say so far that our decentralization has
caused more benefits than defects
but nobody seems to copy us well but
that's absolutely true but i would say
this decentralization won't work unless
you have the right kind of culture
accompanying it yeah but we do yeah we
do but
and dependent on it and greg will greg
will keep the culture
if we had if we had a culture
of people who were trying to make a lot
of money for themselves in the next five
years
at the top it would not have worked no
of course not
and the culture is part of it but
assuming we keep the culture
it will it can go on quite a ways for a
long long time
long long time i think it may amaze
everybody
and by the way the roman empire worked
it worked as long as it did because it
was so decentralized
charlie says to me you won't know yeah
argent greg warren spends his days
reading
and his literature of choice is annual
reports how do each of you spend your
days
what do you what do you read and how do
you review investment decisions
uh in my job i spend a lot of my time
reading deals that people brokers and
people send us reading what they're
proposing trying to analyze them
having a point of view whether it is
something that is of interest to us or
not
uh i might add i do not spend a lot of
time reading annual reports because i'm
not in the stock picking business per se
but in terms of keeping track of what's
going on in the insurance business
that's what
90 of my reading is all about generally
in a day what i'm going to focus on when
i'm reading is
really around our businesses what
industries are in i'm trying to
understand
what our competitors are doing what's
the fundamental risks around those
businesses how they're going to get
disrupted and then it
always comes back to are we allocating
our capital
properly in those businesses relative to
the risk we're seeing
both in our business and and in the
industry so a lot of times spent on that
and
as that knowledge is built at sharing it
back and forth with our management teams
of those uh
relevant subsidiaries and and sort of
fine-tuning it
is really the the approach both of these
fellows can absorb
information to an extraordinary degree
i mean they have and for one thing
they're terribly interested in it
i mean you know and and it's theirs uh
so i'm amazed at both of them
the degree which they just sort of know
everything
and uh but they enjoy it
i mean they're not thinking about
whether you know they'll get the next
job but
that opens up at some huge place or
anything like that nobody leaves us you
know basically the the ones we
we want and uh
but you you really got to kind of be in
love with your business
and and that that that makes a huge
difference and that means that we've got
to have the conditions
that allow that love to to
flourish and and it wouldn't flourish
under many
under my with many organizations so what
do you think about robin hood and other
trading apps or fintech companies
enabling all ages and experience to
participate in the stock market
well i'm looking forward to reading the
s1 on
on uh robin that's a big thing you file
with the fcc when you
are going to be offering securities and
uh
it's you know it's become
a very significant part
of the casino aspect of the casino
group that uh has joined into
the stock market in the last year year
and a half and uh
uh i do want to say how concerned about
how they handle the source of income
when they they say they
they don't charge the customer or
anything i mean
you know uh uh well it'll just be
interesting to watch out describe it i
mean it but
but they have attracted
maybe set out to attract but they have
attracted
uh i think i read where 12 or 13
of their their
casino participants were dealing and put
some calls i looked up
on apples you know the number of
seven-day calls and
14-day calls outstanding and
i'm sure a lot of that is coming through
robin and that's a bunch of people
writing
they're gambling on the price of apple
over the next seven days or 40 there's
nothing
you know there's nothing illegal about
it there's nothing immoral
but uh uh
i don't think he'd built a society
around
people doing it i mean if a group of
a group of us landed on a desert island
we knew he would never be rescued
and i was one of the group and i said
well i'll set up the exchange over here
and i'll i'll trade trade our corn
futures and everything around
i think i i think the the
degree to which a very rich society
uh can reward people who now
know how to take advantage essentially
of the gambling instincts of the not
only american public worldwide public
it uh
it's it's not the most admirable part of
the of
of the accomplishment but i think what
america's accomplished is pretty
admirable overall
and i think actually um american
corporations have turned out to be a
wonderful place
for people to to
put their money and save but they also
make
terrific gambling chips and if you cater
to those gambling ships
when people have money in their pocket
for the first time
and you tell them they can make 30 or 40
or 50 trades a day
and you're not charging them any
commission but you're selling your order
flow or whatever
it it i hope we don't have more of it
i'll put it that way and i will be
interested in reading the prospectus
charlie
well that is really
waving the red flag of the bull
i i think it's just god-awful that
something like that would draw
investment from
civilized men and decent citizens
it's it's deeply wrong
we don't want to make our money selling
things
that are bad for people but
we've got the states doing it with the
lottery you know i know but that's
bad too yeah and i understand very
quickly once you very very
one of the things that's wrong with it
it's getting respectable to be
to do these things
the states are just as bad as robin hood
well in a sense they're worse
i mean they're they're really taxing i
know it's basically i know
i know yeah they're taxing hope
not only that and they don't get much
taxes
the states in america replaced the mafia
as the proprietor of the numbers game
that's what happened
yep they pushed the mafia outside and
said that's our business not yours
it doesn't make me proud of my
government when i
when i was a kid my dad was in congress
they had a numbers runner in the house
office building actually
from raw material purchases by berkshire
subsidiaries are you seeing signs of
inflation beginning to increase
we're seeing very substantial inflation
it's very interesting i mean
we're raising prices people are raising
prices to us
it's being accepted i mean it's not uh
if we get well
you know take home building i mean you
know the cost of
we've got nine home builders and in
addition to our manufactured housing
and then uh operation which is the
largest in the country so we really do a
lot of housing
the costs are just up up up steel costs
uh you know just every day uh
they're they're going up and that there
there hasn't yet been because the wage
the wage stuff follows i mean if the the
uaw
writes a three-year contract we got a
three-year contract but if you're buying
steel
at general motors uh or some place
you're paying more every day
uh so uh
it's it's an economy really
uh it's red hot i mean and we weren't
expecting it i mean
all our companies when they they thought
when when they
were allowed to go back to work you know
what uh
for various operations they would we
closed the furniture stores i mentioned
you know
if they were closed from six weeks or so
on average and
they didn't know what was going to
happen when they when they open up and
you know
they can't stop people from buying
things and we can't deliver them but
they say well that's okay
nobody else can deliver me there and
we'll wait for three months or something
to sort but the backlog grows
and then we thought it would end when
the 600
payments ended and i think you know
around august of last
year it just kept going and it keeps
going and it keeps going and it keeps
going and i get the figures
every week i call or bumpkin calls me
and we go over day by day what happened
at
three different stores in chicago and
kansas city and dallas and
and it just won't stop uh people have
money in their pocket and
and they pay the higher prices and and
when carpet prices go up in a month or
two
you know we announced the price increase
for april for our costs are going up
supply chains all screwed up you know
for all kinds of people
but it's a bike it's almost a buying
frenzy
except certain areas you can't buy it
you can
you know you really can't buy
international air travel and there's
so the money is being diverted from a
little some a piece of the economy
into the rest and everybody's got more
cash in their pocket than
except for meanwhile you know
it's a terrible situation for a
percentage of the people
the you know this suit i haven't worn a
suit you know for a year practically and
that means that the dry cleaner nurse
just went out of business i mean
nobody's bringing in suits to get dry
cleaned and nobody's nobody's bringing
in white shirts uh
to go to the place where my wife goes
it's the small business person if he
didn't have takeout
and delivery services firm
restaurants she got killed on the other
hand if you've got takeout facilities
you've done
you know same source tales of dairy
queen are up a whole lot and they
adapted them
but it's it it is
not a price sensitive economy right now
in the least and
uh i don't know exactly how when it
shows up in different price indices but
there's there's more inflation going on
than quite a bit more inflation going on
than people would have anticipated
of just six months ago we're thereabouts
yeah there's one very intelligent man
who thinks it's dangerous
and that's just the start when we look
at steel prices timber prices
any petroleum input you know
fundamentally there's pressure on those
uh raw materials i do think something
you've touched on one and it
it goes really back to the raw materials
there's a scarcity of product right now
of certain raw materials it's impacting
price and the ability
to deliver the end product but you know
that scarcity factor
is is also real out there right now as
as our businesses
address that challenge and it may be the
some of that's contributed or
arisen from the storm we previously
discussed in texas
when you take down that many
petrochemical plants in one state that
the rest of country is very dependent
upon it we're seeing it flow through
both on price but overall in scarcity of
product which
obviously go together but uh there's
there's challenges that's for sure
what do you think of quantz jim simon's
medallion fund has done 39
net of fees for three decades which
proves that it works
will you consider hiring a quant
lieutenant in berkshire to work
alongside
with ted or todd well i'll say no to the
second part now but charlie handled the
first part
well that's rather interesting that the
the
leading quant fund did fabulously on the
short-term trading
they found little algorithms that worked
to make them
add predictive value and as long as they
kept working they just kept doing it
as long as the money kept coming in when
they got to using the same
system just to finding some little
algorithm and trying to do it
mechanically
for long-term stock predictions the
record was not nearly as good
and in the short-term stuff they found
that if they tried to do it too much
they destroyed their own advantage so
there was a limit on the amount they
could make
but they were very very smart yes they
got very rich very very smart and very
smart and very rich yeah
and and very high grade by the way yeah
jim simons
but uh we're not we're not trying to
make money trading stocks i mean
the answer we don't think we know how to
do it i mean it doesn't
if we knew how to make a lot more money
making trading signs we'd probably be
trading stocks too but but
we don't know how to do it and we really
don't trust anybody else to do it for us
that's simple mr buffett has espoused
for decades the philosophy of buy and
hold
or or hold forever was too short of a
time period
is it a misperception on my part or has
his philosophy changed it seems to be
a much greater turnover in the equity
portfolio lately i don't think there's
that much
turnover i mean but no there's too much
why
there's way too much
yeah it's still too much it's in the
same amount
yeah yeah i'd agree with that and
and the truth is we own our businesses
are equities
so we own 400 or 500 billion and
maybe more in businesses we don't we
don't turn them over at all we don't
resell businesses we
we could probably well we won't even get
into that what we could do but we we
don't do it
and uh and we we do relatively
little and charlie says we'd do better
if we'd if
not if we if i'd done less
warren buffett's 2013 letter in the
middle of page 21 made a prediction that
in the next decade you'll see lots of
really bad news about pensions
given recent events like covet 19 and
that 2023 is two years away would mr
buffett like to comment or revise his
2013 prediction
in a very limited i mean a terrible way
called it
improves the pension position the fewer
the more
it's you know it uh yeah you have less
pensioners
but but the pension situation is
terrible
and in a great many states it's it's not
it's not so bad at the corporate level
and there's some multi-employer plans
obviously they've got problems but
basically
uh it's a terrible problem for the
states and of course
some states and states are going to go
to washington now and say
you know we all want to get a lot of
money because we had these terrible
things happen to us during
during the pandemic which they did but
some of those states have enormous
pension deficits and
they'll come again if they get they had
to check once
it may turn out to be a federal
obligation de facto or something that
then a state situate it has not gotten
better
it's not gotten better at all and uh
obviously
uh and to a certain extent
the pension managers get more and more
desperate as
interest rates go down so they'll
they'll listen to almost anybody that
promises them
they've always had that tendency anyway
but they they'll listen to people
that promise them that they're going to
one way or another solve their problem
for them and
uh that isn't going to work
so it's a big big big problem and of
course the real problem
is let's just take a hypothetical state
that has a huge pension deficit
and maybe even has a cost of living
factor in it which is
going to really be a killer and
you can move if you're an individual
charlie won't move to say that 500
he's not going to move to nevada or
someplace but but you can move if you're
an individual to some degree
particularly rich and old and retired
yeah and and
you can actually take away an asset from
that kind of environment
and give it to another state that
doesn't really need it as much
so you'll get adverse selection over
time
but if you're a company and you put a
plant there
you can't move the plant in 5 or 10 or
20 years so
as the taxable base of individuals
falls down uh
simply because people select out of
being a part of the population
you can't select out very well as a
corporation so you have to be very
careful
and think a long time before you go into
some state with a huge pension deficit
and a declining population
because you're going to be the last man
left and
the pensions won't go away and i don't
think
well anybody with a short-term outlook
doesn't worry about that you know i mean
you know just got me to pass the next
election and
i'm all right on that one you know but
the
you know we we don't want to be
we're not going to steal plants that's
going to be around for 50 years in some
place
where the population gets halved and the
richer part
gets cut you know dramatically even more
dramatically
and we still got a valuable plant there
and we got to keep operating and
and we're going to one way or another
we're going to it's not going to be a
good place to be
that's a good answer when it reminds me
of my old harvard law professor he used
to say
let me know what your problem is and
i'll try and make it more difficult for
you
[Laughter]
what's the biggest lesson both of you
learned during the last year
well my biggest lesson is has been to uh
listen more to charlie
he's been right on some things that i've
been brought on well i don't know
if you're not a little confused by
what's going on you don't
understand it it's just
it is we're in sort of uncharted
territory
we enjoy in a crazy way
actually seeing what happens i mean and
and
this is this has made us
halfway through the movie much more
interested in watching even more
this is an unusual movie but but
we our basic principles of
you know we start with the fact we don't
want to disappoint the people who love
their money with us
and things fall out of that and we may
disappoint people that they don't make
quite as much money as
but we don't and we've seen it
some strange things happen in the world
in the last year and 15 months and
and uh we we've always recognized the
fact
stranger things are going to happen in
the future and and
and i would say if anything is
reinforced
you know our desire well to
figure out everything possible we can do
to make sure that
berkshire is 50 or 100 years from now
you know every bit the organization and
then something that it is now
charlie well of course that's the idea
i think it's pretty likely to work
yeah well we wouldn't have spent 55
years at it unless we did
yeah i would just like to add one final
comment that
that uh i really hope and i think the
odds
are very very good that we get to hold
this next year in
in omaha and i hope that we uh
get a record turn out of berkshire
shareholders and
we look forward to we really look
forward to meeting you uh
in allah uh i guess it'll be next uh
april 30th uh uh but
we'll we'll be sure that day a little
later so
thank you for for watching and uh
we will see you next year and hopefully
in omaha
meetings adjourned